supply chain is uh not doing any better
i'm seeing a bunch of photos from
reporters based in dc of empty shells
and gensake answering a question just
says oh the case of the delayed
treadmill am i right guys yeah i don't
know kind of like the food and the gas
prices and now we're learning that
truckers i i don't well i think it's
truckers but empty shipping containers
are just being dumped in the streets
congesting up everything
so uh yeah i think it's fair to say
things are getting a little bad but
techie also has got another one for us
you said rising prices are good it means
there's an increase in demand
so when you can't buy food just keep it
you know deep inside you'll you'll feel
good knowing that other people want to
buy the same product as you i'm sure
that will feed your children
now they're offering a hundred thousand
dollar salaries fifty thousand dollar
bonuses to try and get people to drive
these trucks wow i wonder what that's
doing to joe biden's approval rating
which obviously is just absolutely in
the gutter
according to civics right now among
independent voters 26
it's that bad we got a lot to talk about
there's a lot of news the nih issued a
statement saying actually yeah we were
funding gain of function research the
whole time
and uh you know that thing about what
fauci was saying well
they're they're in panic mode they're
definitely panic mode and one last
little thing in this intro i noticed as
a subreddit called buy by job and i was
reading it and it's supposed to be
mocking people who lose their jobs but i
got to tell you the whole front page was
like a white pills like inspirational
optimism it was just tons of people
saying i will not comply with these
mandates and i am leaving my job you
know screw this and they're being made
fun of i don't care what the comments
are to see all of these stories about
people police officers high ranking
officials all saying no to the mandates
i'm like wow feeling pretty good
we'll talk about all of this stuff
joining us today is joey b tunes
so brother first of all i just want to
apologize in advance for having me on
i mean i appreciate you having me on but
i can't even make a two-minute youtube
video without getting pulled from the
platform and you guys want to have me on
for two hours dude i think you made a
mistake tim
i play luke i'm the one who got you here
don't blame me
thanks joey i appreciate that very much
um the other day luke was like my views
are down what's happening
hey lydia why don't you have joey
i'm making no promises i couldn't even
talk about the milk crate challenge
remember that when all the dummies were
stacking the milk crates on top of each
other yeah well we'll we'll we'll we'll
do our best to make sure uh we don't get
pulled i suppose but uh so so what do
you do you're a commenter yeah yeah
document the decline of humanity
oh that's what i do i try to raise
awareness to the idiocracy going on in
the world
which it is which is
youtube milk crate challenge things that
i can't talk about apparently i don't
like when i talk about dummies i do like
your gold plaque over here by the way i
still never got my silver plaque which
one
oh no
it's like that
all right i still never got my silver
plaque but yeah things are bad but hey
at least if your name is brandon you're
pretty popular right now so at least we
got that going for a lot of people
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings and finally i was able to get my
let's go brandon t-shirt it just came in
the mail you could get yours also on the
best political shirts.com i'm very happy
about it i have the family friendly
version here
you know the youtube regulations they
never gave me my server plaque as well
that's okay i also got a couple emails
about people saying that the shirts came
out different if they do you should
email the people that produce them we
work with a bunch of different t-shirt
companies one of them is teesprings if
they have your order that is wrong email
them they'll send you a new shirt or a
refund right away so yeah thanks for
having me geez great to be here thank
you luke uh joey great to see you man
hey i appreciate it man i'm glad i made
it here i was on the no-fly list
yeah well welcome well thanks i am very
excited to be documenting the downfall
of western civilization at least we can
laugh while we're doing it right
absolutely what we do here anyways for
now company yeah we're live we're going
after comedy too that's true yeah well
we got you know we just got free
damastan we got a bunch of projects
we're gonna be building stuff chicken
city is almost done i think tomorrow
chicken city might be officially done
epic and then we gotta set the cameras
and the computer and everything but then
we're gonna have a 24 7 live camera show
uh on chickens live chicken show i
should say and what we want to do is we
want to build a machine that whenever 50
in super chats comes in it will dispense
treats for the chickens yeah so then
they'll be like a limit on how much the
chickens can get in terms of the treats
but you know people will be like yeah
let's do it let's get the chickens and
then maybe we'll do something based on
shares like if we get enough shares in
the day like crickets you know pop out
from a box or something but uh we'll
we'll we'll talk about that stuff before
we get started my friends we got an
awesome sponsor we got virtual shield
head over to surfinginternetsafe.com
and you can stay safe with 50 off for
life virtual shield is a virtual private
network service this is a basic layer of
security for you as you browse the web
and it's something that's that's
probably important to have here's the
way i explain it we don't expect people
to break into our houses but we do lock
our windows we do lock our doors
if you want to have that little bit of
security you want to close your blinds
make sure nobody's peeking in trying to
steal your stuff a vpn is a good way to
do it and you've got government actors
you've got major corporations always
tracking yourself and just probably some
standard old black hat hacker who might
be trying to snoop around to steal your
stuff
so head over to surfing internet safe
and they say you can enjoy 24 months of
online security from the world's easiest
and fastest vpn and that's only 59.88
that's actually 77 off the whole package
but you get 50 off all add-ons and other
great discounts on their other plans
they're also proud to announce this
month all discounts are guaranteed for
life that means fifty percent off for as
long as you are a customer virtual
shield the first sponsor that we've ever
had they've stuck stuck through
everything with us and we're eternally
grateful for companies that want to
support the work we do because you know
how important it is you watch the dave
chappelle stuff and you see these these
woke mobs are absolutely coming after
people so companies that straight up say
no we're gonna we want to get behind
this it's good for business
it should be good for their business
especially so give them some support go
to surfing internetsafe.com get virtual
shield and don't forget to go to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have a members only segment coming up
around 11 or so p.m and i imagine that's
when we'll unleash joey to his his
speaking of the dave chappelle special
you guys watch that yeah no not yet oh
you got to watch the it's the last joke
i mean the last joke i mean talking
about daphne if anyone watches they know
exactly what i'm talking about but what
the media tried to do to this guy to try
to spin and he's trying to find some
common ground i mean i'm not going to do
it just i'm not going to tell the joke
but i mean this guy was basically
proving that her own people
were caused her potentially to kill
herself and the media is trying to spin
it out again like they like for some
reason
yeah well they can't for some reason
nuance is gone in this country like the
world is very multicolored and gray and
i feel like people look at it as black
and white so when they hear a story
about a trans person or something and
there's a joke attached to it they feel
like it's it's poking fun like it's a
protected class of people but i don't
know about you guys like as men
that's how we we have camaraderie is
poking each other and and busting each
other's chops and i think that it's a
sign that we like you you know so when a
comic is the guy that is the king of
that and and i just i'm just fascinated
that still in 2021 people just cannot
understand the concept of a comedian and
it just drives me nuts that they're not
you know what i mean i think they can
but i just think that we have become a
nation of cowards and i'm not saying the
people who watch the show i'm not saying
every single person i'm just saying
we've become a nation with way too many
but we can definitely talk about the
decision for sure because you know
there's a lot to talk about that i was
talking about that earlier dave
chappelle said he's going to strike back
he's like if they cancel me i'm going to
do 10 shows all right the biggest cities
screening this so before we get in all
that don't forget to like this video hit
that like button right now smash it and
share this show take the url post it
wherever you can and help support the
work we do but let's talk about the big
uh the big news here check this out we
got the story from the daily mail
driving a hard bargain haulage firms
offer a hundred thousand dollar salaries
and fifteen thousand dollar bonuses to
lure eighty thousand truckers and ease
supply crisis as empty shipping
containers are dumped in the streets
because california port is full
this is a trucker problem check this out
they say near the ports of los angeles
and long beach transportation execs say
the problem isn't a lack of drivers it's
mass congestion caused by empty
containers
steam ships are refusing to take back
empty containers and charging trucking
companies a per diem to store them
that is what is driving some small
businesses to close the logistical
situation at the as the ports worsen
head of the california trucking
association has called for a state of
emergency to be imposed it all ties to
supply chain chaos that's left cargo
ships queuing for weeks to unload goods
to trucking to trucking companies which
are unable to effectively move them so
christmas canceled what's going on they
can't get can't get that little stretch
they're dumping way more than uh
containers in the streets of california
have you been to san francisco
they're dumping in the streets there's a
lot of dumping going on yeah i'm sure
heroin harry right now sitting in front
of a city hall right now is doing a
different type of dumping
but uh
i i told you tim you signed up for this
i signed up for this yeah are we blaming
now back on this topic um
let's get back to dumping
yes i think it's also important to point
out that a lot of container ships don't
want to go back with empty containers
because they don't get paid for shipping
nothing and there's no reason for them
to go back and forth when they have
nothing to ship back one of the reasons
they have nothing to ship back is
because of the slowdown and destruction
of manufacturing in this country but
also the fact that there was a lockdown
those lockdowns that happened months ago
almost a year ago the the ramifications
of it are being felt right now now what
happens now it's it's not just going to
play out for christmas it's going to
play out beyond that because we're
talking about consumer goods not just
for you know chinese made slave made
good toys for your child we're talking
about tools we're talking about
essential items that other businesses
need to create different kind of
products to put products together so all
of that is going to be in in disrepair
to the point where even florida has just
announced that they're going to be
opening up their ports and a lot of
ships are considering literally going
through the panama canal into florida as
florida has announced hey this is a
crisis we could help fix it let's bring
all the goods here we could ship them
around the country but the the crisis
here there's many layers to it because
it's not just a labor shortage it's not
just a trucker shortage it's also uh
emission laws that the governor of uh
california has put that has limited the
specific trucks that could move in the
specific ships that could move in as
well it's also the vax mandates that
specifically make sure that a lot of
people can't work when they want to work
and it's also people saying hey uh the
dollar's not worth crap the government
is hyperinflating it it's printing it
out of thin air it's not worth nothing
why should i work when i can't even
afford uh
to live when gas is skyrocketing up in
california you know what people don't
realize
is that when these shipping containers
can't make it in these companies have
started contracting private vessels to
like trying you know private ports and
stuff like that and so now we're hearing
that what would normally cost like two
grand in shipping is going to cost 10
times that 20 25 that means your
products are going to go up not just
because of demand but because of
the supply chain breaking is increasing
the cost of shipping tenfold that's
going to come down in this product
now check us out in this daily mail
article they actually show this this
doll this is the this is the craziest
thing about it look at this let me
scroll down
this is an american girls sold out
blonde winter princess doll retailed for
250 bucks is now going for up to a
thousand dollars on platforms such as
mercari and ebay whoa
yeah wow i mean they're even talking
about bringing in the national guard to
help them get rid of these cargo ships
but but but again uh they're gonna
offload the cargo ships where are they
gonna put all the empty containers
exactly and the global supply chain
again it runs on its own kind of
volition uh it's not centrally
controlled it's not organized it runs
when there's a need for it now if
there's nothing going back there's no
point for people even shipping things in
so there's a lot of chaos a lot of
disarray and everything that happened
has a
direct fingerprint of the government
intervening saying that they're going to
help everyone when they're causing these
problems and only exacerbating them that
much worse yeah
you will own nothing and you will be
happy exactly this is a part in my
opinion the great reset and screwing
people over this is what you got to
understand about stuff like when the
government gets involved when you you
can tell they're applying a pressure in
some way they're not going to come out
right and be like we're shutting down
the port because people would revolt
but you throw some sticks and stones in
the way some wrenches and some spokes
make it a lot harder for businesses to
operate and then you watch them slowly
struggle out and then gasp their last
breath and then their store closes down
and then there you go you will own
nothing this is like another iteration
of the lockdown that predominantly helps
out the big billionaire class and screws
everyone else over because when the
average business relies on these kind of
shipping containers amazon walmart
costco they just
they they get their own chips they
literally are able to skirt these rules
and they're able to play by different
set of rules meanwhile everyone else is
screwed here saying hey i don't have
much options here except for paying a
thousand dollars for doll that's 250
yeah people might be wondering why
luke's so angry and it's you know luke
actually uh
dropping hints he wanted the american
girl people did yeah
i did my christmas shopping a couple
weeks ago i was telling my audience
members i was like you should do that
too kamala harris out of all people uh
actually had a uh a moment where she had
some kind of clarity and actually told
people a few weeks ago hey you should do
your christmas shopping now no she's a
conspiracy theorist yeah she's just
trying to she's pushing mlm or something
she's she's trying to griff i can't
stand her she talks to you like you're
like a kid and a gardener you ever
noticed that like hi how are you doing i
imagine if somebody talked to you like
that
i might be like who is this did you see
her she arrived at her own surprise
party and yelled surprised
no
yes
it's a white house the white house video
so we could play it there's no there
shouldn't be any copyright issues with
it but uh
i mean just
this is the perfect epitome of of who is
trying to control you the representation
of just utter insincere knowledge how
does people want to be talked to like
that are they like go ahead
[Music]
surprised them like they did they didn't
know what they were doing
no i mean obviously i think she just
nervously dropped the ball i think it's
funnier to imagine that they were like
everybody you are here by you by are
here by working they're just at lunch
that's the party at all no no they're
like you are hereby required to be in
the cafeteria
it's like what are we for it's mandatory
and they're all standing there and then
comma surprise she's fake you're having
a party for me it's like the most staged
yeah she just can't be human that's the
problem she could do she might not be
human
at this point i mean did you see that
video that she did with youtube specials
say it again she she did a video with i
think it was was it discovery or youtube
tv uh where she was the nasa thing where
she sat down with kids and actually like
she was going blind uh yeah it wasn't
her wasn't there a child actor yeah
actors and she was just going so they
have to stage real life and it wasn't
biden on a stage did you guys ever oh
yeah yeah
soundstage they built i mean it looks
like the white house did we ever have a
president that did that or is that
typical or is that a new thing i never i
don't know i don't think this is i don't
i don't think that's i mean it's new
it's all in front of our face guys
and it's like we just don't want to
realize like it's a show i mean how much
more where's the strings behind them
someone was probably hanging over that
thing with marinette marionettes
aliens
what did you say
struggles to be hold on now you can't
you can't say the word alien because
demi lovato says that it's you know
discriminatory
terrestrials never get my aliens demi
yeah can you imagine what who what does
she do demi lovato she's actually she's
she's a singer she was like a disney
singer or something
now she's just a nut case yeah yeah so
she's the one she's the one that uh
she's no lady gaga or beyonce so her
opinion is nothing she's the one that
lady gaga came out right she's the one
that shamed the frozen yogurt place
that's right for uh having too many diet
options for her and ruining her week
yeah yeah a person with 100 million
people following and she shames a small
business during the height of a pandemic
she could buy 10 of those you know
frozen yogurt places and then do
whatever she wants and said she just
wants to just be mean yeah i'm i'm just
waiting for her to identify as froyo
yeah because she's she's they now right
and then she says i might be end up
being trans well she she got attacked
she got slammed by the left for that did
she yeah because they were saying that
she was she was like just trying to use
it as a marketing style absolutely so
she actually got
yeah that was that was a very quick
segue off of supply chain
have you seen her recently she was
caught with uh paris hilton in hollywood
she looks like a uh a plumber from
arkansas i don't know if you want to
pull that up it's bad dude it's really i
mean i'm not kidding no enough about
demi lovato to care to be honest well
this is the problem people i don't want
to know any of this stuff but people
send me all this crap you know what i
mean and i i like again this is the
downside to being a idiocracy uh
historian or whatever you want to call
me is i i have to look at this stuff i
do this for you guys we appreciate it
yeah i hope so
so i'll tell you what that's why i'm
drinking now this scotch is really good
let's let's use this as a good point you
make here we have the story from the
national review nih admits to funding
gain of function research in wuhan says
eco health violated reporting
requirements so we'll we'll start off
really quickly basically this means
fauci lied but they're not they're
saying oh you know it was gay no
function but we didn't realize it even
though they basically describe it as
gain of function but the reason i'm
bringing this up right now is
you i just totally lost my train of
thought the fact you think just just
just completely took me by surprise i
suppose no the um i remember now um this
is actually not the lead story for daily
mail
the lead story on daily mail was brian
laundry yes i say his name laundry oh
yeah yeah and they were like they found
his body right and so
i'm focused on this stuff like this
stuff takes my attention and i'm like
man what is it going on with these labs
and then you go to daily mail and
they're like that's our second story not
that important that the head of the nih
you know fauci lied to congress
it's crazier that this dude they found
his body and i'm like i mean it is kind
of crazy they found his body but i
really don't care about that so we were
just talking about demi lovato i'm like
i don't know enough about why this
person matters for me to care at all see
what it does though it diverts you it
takes you out it's a spell
they like that except i lost i i i
totally forgot what it was see how
powerful that spell was no it wasn't it
wasn't as soon as i started reading
about fauci and eco health i completely
forgot about brian laundry and the gabi
potatoes but that doesn't happen that
often to you you're pretty you know
spot on well the issue is that that
story is so irrelevant to me it was hard
for me to remember yeah and i'm like
wait i'm talking about what am i talking
about again oh that's right that story i
don't care about yes and it's like i'm
being forced to talk about it yeah so
imagine what 19 year olds like you
tapped into a 19 year old's brain right
right that's how yeah it's not the worst
thing in the world you know it's like uh
what is it that jab jab right hook gary
uh garyvee talks about like the way you
want to sell in business you get a
little bit a little bit a little bit
then you give the big ask and this was
like right do a little bit of crap talk
about the junk talk about the junk and
then you you lay into them with the
fouchy thing and they trust you because
you've been talking their language for a
while well there's a trick in sales
where you get someone to say yes seven
times
and then when you ask them again
they'll be the next question they'll be
more likely to say yes so this is an old
trick so you'd say things like like luke
you like
wings right sometimes yeah of course
like everybody likes wings and like and
and you like pizza maybe and then what
you do is once you get them and say yes
you you do these small questions and
then finally say of course so you
definitely want to buy this
and then they go yeah yeah they're
basically hypnotizing him basically i
mean that's what i mean when you listen
to pop music or something that's why
they say the same word overnight it's
brainwashing i mean you don't think that
powers with people with authority are
using that method on people oh yeah the
word terror has been well but
it's just marketing you know whenever i
explain when i explain to people how the
media manipulates right so actually this
is a really good uh uh
topic when we're talking about fouchy
so
fauci lies
rand paul shows the documents proving he
lies at the at the hearing what do you
get from like reddit our politics they
say fauci schools rand paul and it's all
manipulation all of these marketing
tactics and when i tell people this is
what they're doing
they always say the exact same thing so
here's what i say to people
first thing i'll do is i'll say i bet
you
i can get you to say the phrase yeah but
not me
and then when they're like what like
yeah i bet you all make you say it and
they're like okay i guess then i'll wait
a little bit then i'll explain to them
what the media does and i'll say they
manipulate people here's how they do it
and it works on everybody and they
immediately go yeah but not me
and then i go right remember i said i
was gonna make and i say that because
like nine times out of ten people
respond exactly with that phrase and
i've heard it so much i just bet people
they'll say it yeah and then once they
say it i'm like how did i make you say
it how did i know you were gonna say it
oh it's almost like people are
predictable sure
well look how easy we can be manipulated
i mean you just proved it right there i
mean i would have fell for that too
probably and there's probably other
avenues you can go down to get people to
fall into that trap so you mean again
you mean to say that the people with
authority over people like they're not
using of course they're and i'm blown
away that people don't see enough people
don't see you i mean it's all out in the
open well they learned how to master
emotions and i think that's why daily
mail decided to lead with the brian
story rather than the fouchy story the
fouchy story's factual it's big it has a
lot of huge implications i mean for
frick's sakes we have the nih admitting
that fauci was funding gain of function
research for chimeric bat coronaviruses
which were made to infect human beings
before everything happened humanized
ace2 receptors in mice
just be very specific exactly what
they're trying to argue is but they
weren't in humans
so that means fauci just didn't realize
it was gain of function research exactly
uh but but again they're playing this
this kind of word game when in reality
this is huge this is the nih pointing
directly at fouchy showing how he lied
to congress there should be major
implications here they're talking about
charging bannon for not testifying to
congress they went after roger stone for
lying to congress they showed up with
the fbi at his doorstep with cnn in the
morning hounding him going after him
trying to ruin his life and i'm not the
biggest fan of roger stone but let's
call a spade a spade here he was
targeted politically for lying to
congress fauci
lied through his teeth and also this nih
letter is pretty interesting because
they're giving the echo health group
five days to report to the data of what
actually was happening here so i'm going
to be paying very close attention to
because the echo health group is the
peter dazek group peter dazek was the
same individual that was put in charge
to investigate himself in this entire
saga so so this is this is again
important details that matter but there
are details the brian laundry story
that's emotions that's someone that they
put up there
they put up on the stage and they make
people relate to these personal stories
and because it's personal they lead with
it because they master those
manipulations uh to a perfect t to make
sure that you're distracted with utter
nonsense that has no effect on your life
it's there's no reason that that we
should be talking about this brian guy
there's no reason that this story
affects anyone except him his friends
and his close relatives why should it be
a national story it shouldn't these the
fauchy story should be these people
operate like an abusive husband you know
what i mean i mean this is like
manipulation this is like the mindset of
a serial killer you know what i mean or
a rapist or something like you're
manipulating human beings here our own
government's doing the media as well i
mean like
it's disgusting and nothing ever happens
to these people and who appointed this
bozo to begin with was it uh it was in
the 80s wasn't it he's been he's been
around in government for a very very
long time he wasn't tied to gates he was
tied to gates he was tied to rockefeller
there was many meetings that he had many
times he was photo with a lot of the
ruling establishment a lot of the upper
echelons of very powerful people when
when his emails came out you see direct
communications between him and bill
gates almost as if dr fauci is asking
bill gates what to do next so those
emails are published in the leak demos
that come out there's a lot of
correspondence between them and we don't
hear about this this is this is a major
story this is a big story everyone
should be talking about this but you
know i think also we have to understand
we're seeing through the lens of what
they want us to see so them going with
the lead story
might not even be because more people
click on it there's a possibility i
might be wrong here i probably am wrong
but we have to understand in this
convoluted controlled digital space that
we're all a part of we understand we
need to understand that there's a lot of
manipulation and it's more uh than just
what they show us in the news feed fauci
was appointed by reagan and guess what
year
84. lydia got it 1984. one of the two
reagan just disappointed
he shut down the mental asylums too 1984
dude
we live in a simulation seriously
it's not a coincidence
yeah reagan i watched re-watch some
reagan on the tonight show and that guy
was like a snake i mean he was just he
was an actor he knew exactly
and then he'd pull out some rhetoric we
need to we need to shrink government we
need to fix this and make more jobs and
everyone's clapping and like oh did you
notice the van life stuff how big it got
no
so there was this uh for for for a while
there were very very popular van life
videos it's like people like i live in a
van it's awesome i think i've seen some
a bunch of these videos so i actually i
actually built that event a mobile work
studio so i could travel around and do
the show and stuff now we have an rv
we're building it for a bigger studio
but there was this one woman i forget
her name but she started a channel she
made two videos and gained like three
million subscribers maybe it was like 2
million subscribers
and everyone was like how did this
happen
youtube said something like oh it was a
hiccup in the algorithm
what i think is that youtube was
purposefully promoting van life like in
their algorithm they said
telling people to live in vans down by
the river
yeah and so you combine these things
you've got young woman showering in a
van and it hits all these algorithmic
points and so it just spammed the video
to literally everybody and then they had
to go and like shut it down shut it down
and see the valve is loose it's spraying
everywhere
they want they want to i think youtube
absolutely controls what people see
i think they plan it i think they have
conversations about it that way they can
control public opinion across the board
i agree they they they promote much
worse that i got i got have you ever
typed in nude yoga in youtube
i want people that are watching this
right now and don't you know don't click
off go open a new tab of your browser
right now or on your phone and type in
naked yoga in youtube and then after
that type in dildo challenge no no no no
no hold on hold on a second we can't be
saying something okay but no because i
got to prove a point though because
i want to know what you guys see on
there and then you tell me what i'm
doing wrong or why any of our videos are
being pulled what are they what are they
they're showing explicit adult content
yeah i mean completely and i don't mean
to bring it up because i don't want to
get knocked off here but like somebody's
got to talk about this because what
content creators are getting kicked in
the butt and we're getting pushed to the
side for just basically talking about
the truth or even just reporting the
news now
and and you me and you have all this
degenerate crap that they're pushing on
people and they're fine with and you go
to report that stuff nothing happens but
joey b tunes is the problem luke's the
problem tim's the problem is somebody's
got to talk about it and just the fact
that i can't even bring up right now
what they actually have that's that's
that's what there's a family thing for
us i i know but i'm just saying there's
a problem with the platform
that we can't even talk about what you
can search for on there but they can
keep that actual thing up but if i talk
about it we're at risk of being pulled
well my concern you know the story we
usually tell is when we used a very
common phrase for a group of people that
are in a circle and they happen to be
bad people we call them jerks yes and
then we got some people being like yo
like i play the show with my kid yeah
and driving in the car right and so
we're just trying to like
i understand it's not so much like i i'm
i'm fairly certain we can talk about all
of that stuff it's an issue of just like
how how spicy are we going to get i'm
going to divert to luke you can blame it
but
hey man we'll
talk exchanged
this is just like you know we try to be
careful in in the language with the idea
that that kids are around but youtube
has a series of videos man i can't even
i don't even want to say the names of
these things but youtube has explicit
adult content of men engaging in
adult activity yeah both activities with
other men and like it is it's disgusting
it is shown it is children watch that
stuff just like people watch this show
but you know i would imagine there's a
lot of parents that watch this show too
that now they they know about this kind
of stuff and but you see the concern i
have with like
if there's someone who's playing this
podcast and they're in their car they're
picking their kids from school and
they're going to be like yo right like
not my kids around but imagine when
those kids are on youtube without
supervision and the videos they're
getting so i'll stress it again too you
know because the box has been open
there's a there are videos that i can't
believe exist
of adult men
putting things in their body
on youtube
and they get millions of views and they
have tons of subscribers and youtube
responded to that specific video and
they were questioned on it on twitter
and defended it and yeah so um just just
seeing that and then seeing some of the
sagas seeing you know the political
content that gets hit it definitely does
bring up some very important questions
but if you have a child definitely be
careful i wouldn't just ever leave them
in front of the internet or youtube in
general uh because these are spaces
where
again there's so many different rules
there's so many different videos out
there and you've got to be extremely
careful to what you uh allow
yeah i will clarify the naked yoga she
is doing yoga and is naked but there's
no nudity she's basically not showing it
did you scroll through it was the first
thing i started there's there's tons of
news there's a lot of things there's
tons of i mean i've been kind of vocal
about that particular search term so i
wonder if like they've cleaned it up or
what but i mean it was pretty explicit
huh pretty expensive like full on
interesting
yeah
i i can understand i suppose when
they're like naked yoga is it's not sex
like nudity is different than sex but
they actually have videos of sex oh my
god hard hardcore stuff oh my gosh like
but they they they don't show the
it'll be like the guy bent over with his
face in front of the camera and the guy
behind him so they don't it's like
that's on youtube yeah that's all on
youtube wow it's amazing it's amazing
that they allow that kind of stuff and
they have the nerve to like knock people
off that are just basically reporting
the news i mean like basically that's
what i do i'm like i don't even need to
make jokes anymore i just basically just
read what's going on
and it's just funny on its own you know
and i shouldn't even exist i shouldn't
even have a you know what i mean i
shouldn't be anything at this point but
that's how upside down that the world is
right now there's it's so many
inconsistencies going on with the rules
the community guidelines could you
imagine if if facebook was a country
do you know what you'd have there like i
i got banned because there was an antifa
guy
uh that was had a knife in an apartment
and he says i i just moved to portland
oregon and and if you come at me i'm
gonna stab you or something in his own
words and i called the guy a land mammal
basically and that was that was bullying
so i basically bullied a guy that
threatened an entire city and then they
banned me for that it's just it's it's
incredible that there's no nuance and
and if that's well there's
antifa is clearly protected right right
so this is something we've done for
years
when antifa goes on twitter and makes
direct threats and doesn't get banned
and then a guy says learn to code and
gets nuked yeah it's incredible
nobody does anything i mean what can you
really what can you do i will confirm
there is full frontal on youtube there
you go thank you is it confirmed now
yeah i just saw okay good on youtube i
had no idea i don't mind i mean i think
nudity
should be celebrated in a way and that
maybe society is
oh i pulled it off you want me to show
it oh no no no no no not to you do you
want me to show it to you no no okay i
was going to see if you were in the
search because there's something i could
if you think that's bad yeah wow there's
something i i i don't even want to say
the title of these videos yeah yeah that
we're going viral right yeah
you know we talk about with minds you
know i've co-founded mines and it was a
big thing like should we show nudity
should we have 18 plus and the consensus
is yeah you know some people involved in
mines say no
you know but i think
i mean i don't know man
why why why why hide it i mean they
don't they don't put it on the front
page but i think it goes back to tim's
point about how they they are very
particular about what they show us and
what they allow and there's got to be a
reason do you don't think that they're
aware of that there's got to be a reason
why they don't take that stuff down and
it's not a good reason i don't think
i think that there's a degeneracy going
on and i think they're trying to push
degeneracy i mean like if you guys have
ever seen that video with uh i think
they're trying to demoralize the country
is what i think it is i mean we could
theorize on many different kind of uh
you know we could go down different
avenues as why this is happening but i
think it's very fair to say that adult
content especially when watched by
children has an extremely negative
effect on people's cognitive skills on
their brain development and has very
negative consequences for them as they
grow up that prevents them from having
real intimacy between a man and a woman
so there's there's a larger conversation
to be had i think maybe we should save a
lot of this conversation for the the
post show that's how we get all sweary
that's where we could actually talk
about whatever whatever we want
but but but at the end of the day when
you look at the larger psychological
studies with adult content i mean uh
they destroy the minds of young children
in many different ways whether it's
impulse control whether it's
desensitation
there's a lot to talk about here there's
a lot of research and yeah if you
haven't done it yet and if you think
you're you know
if you think
you know some of the comments i don't
want to just pinpoint you ian but but
there's a lot of bigger understanding
here that's suppressed especially with
the damage that happens with adult
content that isn't talked about that
there's jordan peterson talk about that
yeah i believe so you're talking about
the chat right now people are going nuts
about it right now in the chat you can
see it and and like is nudity adult
content
i don't know it's not sex it's very
different well there's a way to do it
but we're not saying whether it's
yeah we're not talking about that
there's there's full on adult explicit
content yeah and if you don't show
nudity you can still have it like pretty
nice
they they do like man i defer to the
master i will just say
to you guys and i'll try to keep it as
you know family friendly as possible a
man bent over facing the camera
naked with a man behind him and there's
tons of videos like this on youtube now
look if you want to go to you know
pornhub and watch whatever you want i i
don't give a damn but if youtube is to
the greater point if they're gonna
censor you if they're gonna issue a
strike if they're going to give you know
crowder a strike for being a bully or
whatever it's like yo priorities
be consistent none be consistent that's
the problem is that there's
inconsistencies in these ideologies and
it's like they might really believe that
what we're talking about is just not in
the best entrance interest of society
for whatever their reason is whether
there's an agenda or not i'm not going
to get all conspiracy theory about it
but it's like but then be consistent
about about that if you think that if
you're trying to create a community with
guidelines
then don't don't i don't want to
again i go back to facebook was a
country or youtube was it was a
neighborhood i mean imagine all the
stuff that you'd see and that you'd have
the taliban beheading people i mean like
those videos are on you know you have
women twerking in the yard in the front
yard but then joey b goes this is wrong
and then oh you got to get out of the
neighborhood now i mean that's
kill bro they're having a party
one of the problems with them with
consistency is the admins are
interpreting the terms so they're
interpreting them differently like it'll
be like insensitive content right and
then one guy thinks it's insensitive the
other guy doesn't and then whoever's the
admin that day and sees it but
inconsistent business model i want to
get all conspiratorial as you say go
ahead uh because if you break down
intimacy you break down people having
good relationships you break down the
family unit and when you destroy the
family unit people could be more easily
conquered whether this is a grand
conspiracy or not it's happening
there's less families there's less
people having uh harmonious
relationships with each other there's
more people living on their own and
that's why there's you know such some
people speculate such a huge increase in
depression in suicides in the mental
health of the people in the western
world going dramatically down another
reason is because of these lockdowns
that of course were promoted by mr fauci
i'm going to bring this all the way back
to dr fauci now that of course nih just
admitted uh was publicly lying to
everyone on congress which should be a
bigger story and everyone should be
talking about well
we've got we got a story to talk about
we got a segway here it was a crazy uh
uh topic to talk about youtube's gross
are we still on the air we didn't get
pulled yet oh we're still in the airport
i'm trying to get i mean
this is the kind of conversation that
admins have behind the scenes gotcha
here's one
shares of trump-linked spac close up 350
following news of social media deal the
stock of the spat company digital world
acquisition corp skyrocketed on
extremely heavy trading volume after
news of a merger that would launch
former president donald trump's planned
social media platform it searched 357
thursday and trading was halted multiple
times due to volatility wow dweck
was among the top 10 most popular names
on reddit's wall street bets chat room
even exceeding meme stock game stops
mentions
so so so donald trump announced
announces he's going to be launching
truth what is it called truth.social i
believe truth social
true trump social media platform
i mean this would be interesting because
i think he's a little too late he had a
lot of momentum he could have you know
people were begging him to do this when
he was still president of the united
states they were like hey get off the
big tech platforms there needs to be an
alternative and for some reason donald
trump waited and waited and waited and
how is he going to tell everyone about
this social media platform i mean some
media organizations are talking about it
but is he going to email everyone about
this yes i mean he will yeah and that
might work and might not but there's a
lot of people disillusioned with him
there's a lot of people that are
disenfranchised with the whole trump
movement so will this be as popular as
it would have been if he actually did
this when he was president
and you want me to sign up for parlor
and getter and and all of these
platforms like dude i got a handful
already yeah i got twitter i hate it but
i don't really pay much attention to
twitter to be honest like i really don't
care that's where i'm at that's the
least platform i use but i was just
talking to ian earlier about minds like
you were mentioning it because there's
so many coming out like which one do i
go to do i go to rumble do i go to gab
do i go to go to mines i mean what you
know i can't be on everything
you go to trump that's a problem a lot
of people are having we need to build
software that bridges all of them i
agree
there's a lot of alternatives float hive
steemit uh
mines
i can name like
about 10 other ones that you know parlor
that that people use all the time and
and it's hard because you only have echo
chambers there let's be honest and let's
have a real conversation when you go to
these kind of websites it's the same
people that were kicked off it's the
same people that regurgitate usually the
same talking points and if you want to
go where the people are where the
audience is where the normies are where
the kyle's and karen's are you got to go
on twitter you got to go on facebook you
got to go on instagram and that's where
you reach out the most amount of people
and i think that's why there has been
such a boom in censoring people shutting
them down and trying to just slowly
silence them a little bit when they
counter the narrative twitter is
basically like like the town center
where everybody's talking about stuff
yeah and there are other platforms but
they tend to be
very community based you know if you go
to one platform you'll find a lot of
people who are into you know this
particular culture whereas twitter is
very generalist yeah it's a garbage
platform you know yeah but they have the
infrastructure they were able to build
the infrastructure because of their
relationships that they had with
governments that were able to give them
an unfair advantage against everyone
else now when we're talking about rumble
or parlor they don't have that same
advantage they don't have the same kind
of infrastructure as all these big tech
companies that could do things that much
faster that much quicker and have the
user base that they don't have so this
is a very difficult situation what's
that dwack yes what's dwack that's
trump's the thing he merged with dwack
dweck they got to change that name yeah
that's violating the youtube community
guidelines
you think you'd be more clever with that
but trump's rolling out his truth social
to stand up to the tyranny of big tech
oh please i'm not convinced it would
actually i don't think it i don't think
it will and you want to talk about
tyranny apparently this guy forked
mastodon this is what i've been reading
reports on the truth social is a fork of
mastodon and then they abuse the license
they basically it's agpl which means if
you take the code and you change it you
have to make all your changes public and
if they didn't make all their changes
public then they violated the software
license would you come on dude you're
supposed to be running for president
well you're violating this is insane
well that's one source saying it let's
wait because a lot of you know news
around trump has always been kind of
conflated
to say the least so i'm not a trump fan
but i know when i see a headline with
trump in it to take a step back and be
like okay yeah okay let's do some
research on this let's let's get the
textbook out there let's get let's get
the you know let's get all the resources
out there to make sure this is what they
do right with like freedom phone
so when we had the guy from freedom
phone on all these news stories were
like it's a garbage fake you know
whatever and then i just ask him is it a
knockoff and he's like it's a custom
phone and i'm like okay it has it is
based similarly on some of these phones
yes okay so the media is basically
trying to falsely frame what freedom
phone is and act like he's just buying a
phone for 10 bucks and selling it for
20. when in reality it's like they
actually did work developing and setting
we haven't tested them yet the point is
maybe the phones are trash no one's
actually done any forensic analysis on
these things no one's actually run
through them the media just lies
about everything trump's truth social
maybe sued over apparent breach of open
source terms that's from uh washington
example bro it's not even out yet it
says may be facing too it doesn't say
exactly that's up to math well that's
how they get you this might happen this
may be the thing again uh where's the
facts where's the resources where's the
people actually coming out and standing
behind a statement almost every
statement you see in the mainstream
media now is sources said or officials
said you can't believe any of those
people based on the screenshots i have
seen it absolutely is based on mastodon
i didn't realize screenshots was were
forensic evidence yeah like exactly
source exactly so you can't jump the gun
on this stuff yeah no i'm reading uh and
now in this moto article yeah oh gizmodo
bastian's of great journalism i mean
it's not like it i'm not making it up is
what i'm saying yeah i know but like
maybe when they actually launch the
platform we can make a determination
about what they're doing with open
source and whether or not they're
violent filing any licenses this comes
from the people that are in the beta i
think is
if they if they if they're not even if
it's not even publicly available have
they violated any license
i don't know the answer is no yeah most
people talking about trump are are
deranged or mentally defunct in many
different ways and they go into this
fervor where they literally start
connecting dots that are not there and
again not a trump fan people know i'm
not a trump fan but let's be honest here
a lot of the news around him has been
absolutely fake and because that fake
news it galvanizes and double downs his
audience to support him that much more
and if they were just you know honest
and real and tried to actually do some
legitimate reporting maybe we could have
criticized him on actually the bad
things he did because he wasn't a
perfect president he did some bad things
but there was no way to even criticize
him doing bad things because everyone
was just screaming like other idiots so
this guy
michael talon says was able to set up an
account using the handle donald trump on
truth social former president trump's
new website although the site is not
officially open a url was discovered
allowing users to sign up anyway that
sounds like a violation of the computer
fraud and abuse act yeah let's see if
the feds actually go after any of these
people for doing that it's a dumb law by
the way i don't want them to but if if
you if you get a url that you are not
allowed to access and then use it anyway
and try that's actually illegal dumb law
by the way i bring it up because the
government would absolutely go after
anybody who dares oppose the
establishment these people are they're
mocking trump so it'll be totally fine
but that being said how can you violate
a license if the website isn't publicly
open and people are breaking in
yeah a very good point that i'm happy
i'm just i just can't stand it's all
lies all the time
the trump derangement syndrome is real i
mean we all know people who they just
they wake up every morning imagine
letting a guy like that live rent free
in your brain it's it's it's really
fascinating because it's like you think
about it like this is like i always look
at trump as like the uh well okay you
got to figure out what ma what makes
people so upset about trump right it's
because he holds people accountable he's
a lot he's a loud mouth he's like the
guy at the end of the bar that's drunk
saying that he knows how to fix the
country i mean like look i look at him
as like the guy from bar rescue you guys
ever watched that show bar rescue it's a
guy that fixes bars up he's a guy from
long island like a big you know big
buffalo looking guy from long island
people he's just he's like a trump right
so i don't care what that guy says i
don't care what what kind of skeletons
he has in his closet just fix my bar
just like like with trump just fix the
country i don't care i don't need a
daddy up there
that's why i feel like a lot of these
people that hate trump so much who loved
obama so much and they love kamala and
biden all that what do they all have in
common they talk to you like children
they want a daddy they want to feel good
they want everything to be cozy whereas
trump held like said look the world's a
jungle you know what i mean it's like
like there's a lot of problems we got to
take this guy out we got to do this we
got to it's holding people accountable
it's keep it's putting people
you know it's personal accountability
which is which is lost i think he held
people accountable for his actions
whereas like you have biden up there on
a fake stage you know what a what a like
a marinette whatever puppet strings
above him and he's reading the
teleprompter he can't even get through a
sentence after half the time oh i mean
talking back about mastodon i'll tell
you what my criticism of trump is yeah
mastodon's open source
they they they want and encourage people
to create different versions different
rules i i you know i pulled it up opens
free and open source self-hosted social
networking micro blogging similar
twitter blah blah it's not even public
yet
tr uh trump hasn't released this they
found a url to break in maybe when he
publishes he won't put the license you
know credit or whatever in i don't know
it's not the point right now the point
is why are they mad about this yeah why
are they mad at someone for taking the
code and using it and more importantly
why can't trump just build something
well they're mad because it's a gpl
license and if you take gpl and make it
private you're violating gps you made it
private uh if you don't
attribute gpl you don't get it it hasn't
even launched it yet right the point is
that's why trump didn't even do anything
and they're like he's using mastodon
it's like you want people to use it it's
open source that's the point no it's not
free software is different than open
source software imagine if with with uh
open network we were like we've created
this great application people to use and
then as soon as someone we didn't like
use it we were like oh oh i can't
believe someone i don't like is using
the free software we made it's if they
make it proprietary without i mean
that's not happening right now that's my
point they're they're using that as an
excuse to be mad and nothing has
happened it's not even out it's not
publicly available and they're acting
like the apocalypse has already occurred
i know this says that they they in truth
socials claims that all source code is
proprietary that's a claim that
apparently when when when trump takes it
public
and that's there then by all means we
should we should we should definitely
talk about it yeah then you could
criticize it trump could cure cancer and
they'd say doctors are losing jobs it's
because trump is back you guys they get
a chance to write 50 million stories
about how he's screwing everything up
already this site's not even open and
they're jumping down his throat for what
they have absolutely no evidence they
have screenshots they got into a url
they weren't supposed to get into and
they're like oh my gosh trump's doing
everything wrong oh really like you were
telling us for the past don't they
realize this backfires now we're all
interested in this right exactly well
to add to your point uh joey there trump
definitely kind of represents the tough
father and the democrats kind of
represent the deranged crazy cat lady
that smells like pee uh in my opinion
because they're just like totally
unhinged totally not talking about the
topics and they're trying to blame
everything on trump trying to blame
everything on the dad trying to blame
everything on him him him him him and
and again he he made some mistakes i
criticized him throughout his presidency
i think he deserved some criticism but
none of that criticism was even heard uh
because of the insanity that was created
by these people that literally had no
talking points no basis to even attack
him on daddy issues exactly the silver
lining here is if he is using a mastodon
fork that means it's part of the
fetiverse which means that if he opens
up the code which you're supposed to do
then we can integrate with it this is
really great this is this is good yeah
yeah the feta verse is basically uh let
me read this uh to you guys about
mastodon what trump's social network
basically does
they say uh for mastodon gab a
controversial network blah blah blah far
right changed its software platform to a
fork of macedon and became the largest
mastodon node in july 2019 that's right
mastodon the biggest node is gab
in response mastodon's main contributors
stated in their blog they were
completely opposed to gaap's project
philosophy criticized gab they blocked
the content saying was all racist or
whatever but they could only block it
from their servers what that means is
truth.social if trump gets it up and
running and you have an account on it
maybe macedon says we're banning trump's
platform but they can't ban you
this is good news especially for the
stuff we're working on using the
fetiverse
we're getting away from the centralized
control of communications no more
zuckerberg wojiski or whatever dorsey
deciding to nuke your account because
it'll be your private website
services can decline service to you but
you can always find an alternative where
there's real competition so this is this
is good this is good stuff good good
good job trump i agree it's gonna be how
do you think people are going to take to
it do you think it's going to be i mean
it also depends because if people attack
it like they're already attacking it
it's going to bring more attention to it
it's going to bring more followers to it
but it's going to be interesting if
they're going to launch like
infrastructure attacks on if trump is on
it
the media will be forced to be on it
these journalists will have no choice
yeah because trump will be posting and
they have to cover it i forgot about the
trump reply guys
they want their jobs back
yeah jeff he was like i remember he
tweeted something about almost quitting
and then he's like i got to figure
something out because i don't have
anything other than trump my identity is
defined by there is entire careers built
off replying to trump tweets
there's entire books there's books being
sold of all of his tweets right now that
are sold out
so again
the guy was uh interesting the guy was
funny the guy
knew how to get attention and um
you know i i think i think a lot of his
trolling a lot of his comments are
desperately needed in the kind of
sanitized digital world that we're
living in i know a guy
he used to be a regular journalist
normal dude
a little regular millennial guy and then
one day he responded to trump and he
said something dumb made no sense added
to the conversation but then he got
followers
and then he kept doing it and then i was
talking to him and i was like like what
are you what are you doing like you know
you used to cover serious topics and
he's like oh i'm just you know
responding to trump
and then after like a couple of years
he had destroyed his career completely
he
was unable to my understanding get
serious journalistic work started
working for activists
and then when trump left
it's all over
imagine destroying your life as a
serious reporter because you found out
you're getting followers by calling
trump a poo poo head wow what a life
what a life that's funny those type of
people too those are the same people who
remember remember when they would say
that trump was they were worried about
if he was unfit for office right now
look at who we have the guy's probably
down the street getting spoon fed in a
rocking chair right now watching johnny
the blanket on his back yeah remember
when he said that he what did he call
that guy the uh dog-faced pony liar tony
soldier pony soldier what is that from
an old western no it's not true it's not
true so
at first the media was like it's
actually an old line from a movie and
then someone pulled the movie up and
it's like
it's like he took three different movies
and mashed random things together
lion dog faces with ponies consistent to
his brand basically when he speaks have
you guys seen freedom tunes new uh i
like those yeah the rogan one i haven't
seen a new one no the new one is joe
biden's greatest hits oh i gotta watch
and it's like
you're not shopping of pressure coming
down on me and i'm like oh sheamus so
good out of the park out of the park i
do this thing with biden now whereas
like i try to i want to make it a whole
presidential term without actually
listening to what the president has to
say so i try not to get through like one
when he shows up on my feet i try to cut
it off before the end of his sentence
which is easy to do because he doesn't
actually form sentences so it's easy to
do that but um i just feel like it's a
waste of time to listen what he's saying
he's reading from a teleprompter he
doesn't believe in what he's saying he
has people behind him tell him what to
do
let me if he can read the teleprompter
let me point out the differences we have
right here now i can't speak for every
person on the right there's a lot of
people who were who replied to biden and
kamala and it's like the weirdest thing
it's i find it's the most annoying thing
to me honestly i don't care from the
left or the right i'll see a tweet from
like kamala harris i'll click it and
then i'll see a bunch of verified like
libertarian moderate or right-wing
people just saying stuff like you're so
dumb like you're wrong about i'm like
why are you playing reply guy to biden
it's just so strong why i even
acknowledge it why even acknowledge him
into your life it's like
demi lovato thing like why waste your
time even writing that in but i will say
this
when trump would say something people
would just call him stupid they'd say
you're evil you're racist you're a bigot
you're dumb
and now you know now they're like wait
what'd you say what yeah
this policy is incorrect and you know
you're failing but there's a lot of the
same stuff there's a lot of the same
reply guy stuff but i will say the big
difference is that
there's no real career reply guys for
biden you're not going to gain followers
by replying to biden like you could
reply to trump right and so this bread a
class of people who made a living my
favorite is when like these these people
like jeff what's his face i want to say
his name
anyway
people like him
who would be like if you like my insult
of trump please here's my paypal link
and give me money that's so cool here's
my here's my patreon wow who are these
people you know people like that i knew
one guy uh yeah he's his kid career's
over he must be fun at parties
yeah you know what the reality is normal
dude these are normal people and then i
got to tell you when you have like
i i i can't imagine having this
mentality but this guy he's got like a
thousand followers which is like you
know bottom rung and then all of a
sudden he has two thousand followers all
because he trump he called trump a dumb
ass or something yeah and then after a
week he's like i'm gaining tons of
followers so what they do is they pull
up trump's twitter and they would just
refresh and then as soon as it would
come in they'd immediately be like oh i
got to be the first person what a sad
existence oh terrible they set up
notifications and we have to understand
big tech social media rewarded these
people they were able to get all the
followers all the replies all the likes
they saw the conflict social media said
ooh conflict let's put this up on the
front page let's put this up so everyone
sees it and they got their response they
loved donald trump they loved every
aspect of him even though they hated him
even though they said he was they
scorned him even though they cursed him
out whenever they could even though they
attacked them disingenuously whenever
they could at the end of the day the big
tech social media companies and and also
let's not forget uh the mainstream media
loved him because he
revitalized their entire careers that
were already going downhill they're
going downhill right now because we have
a president that barely even tweets but
barely even says anything coherently
that they can't even respond to yeah
it's sad they love the divide too which
is kind of the saddest thing that's why
i feel like what we need to do because
we're always at odds it's the left
versus the right you turn on cnn they're
pointing fingers at the right you turn
on fox news they're pointing fingers at
the left why don't we just take the
north east the south the mid the middle
america and the west coast and just form
our own countries with our own
governments and our own presidents and
then you go where you fit into and then
you leave everyone the hell alone
because it's like what are we going to
do it's a constant tug-of-war battle
going on you get a democrat in office
and then you get a republican undo with
the previous president if we're lucky
yeah yeah so you know so i pulled up
someone someone commented in super chat
it's truthsocial.com you can join the
waiting list so people have found ways
to effectively gain access to the site
i'm going to tell you this right now
the first people to sign up for that
waiting list reply guys
yep trump's
what's the opposite of a sycophant
someone who walks around complaining
about your farts
files
and you know what i'm willing to bet
they cried
i'm willing to bet they were sitting
there when they heard this announcement
they just like started crying like
they mattered
please trump please let me on your
platform and these are the same people
that called for him to get banned and
now they're they're getting wow that's
what i was saying when when they were
talking about banning trump i was like
it'd be really bad for them because they
need trump to be their boogeyman and it
has been it absolutely has been because
now they're the power in charge they're
the ones that everyone's looking at like
okay you got everything you needed you
got rid of the bad boogie man now show
us what you got and what you got is an
absolute utter crap storm on huge epic
proportions of financial calamities
facts mandates more people getting sick
more people dying from the sickness than
they did under donald trump which they
blamed for every single person that
passed away now more people are dying
and then biden oh yeah he's got his
fault we should make an account on
twitter called like trump scarecrow or
whatever
and it's just like it's a fake trump
account so that the reply guys have
somewhere to be and to like you know
it's like their safe space yeah yeah so
it's you know it brings them back to the
good old time glory days when they were
getting followers
and and some kind of attention but it's
it's it's mainly an attention game here
and that's the weird part because
they've been incentivized to know the
dirtier the nastier the the more
disgusting they are the more people look
at them and there's a certain point to
that where people are like oh you're
really ugly but there's there's there's
the initial part like oh well there's a
car wreck over there let's let's at
least look make sure whatever's going on
there there's this kind of initial first
look so i think we reached that point
where it's just utter disgust and people
realize how nasty it is and
and the algorithm feeds it to people and
i think a lot of people eventually not
yet i don't think we're there yet but i
think eventually are going to be utterly
disgusted with what the timeline
provides for them
did you find mastodon in the source in
the inspect the code on the page no i
just said inspect but apparently it's in
there yeah it says mastodon and it's
definitely says it's proprietary in the
terms of service
in the terms of service here that's the
link there yeah but it's not live yet it
could be a placeholder well it's right
we don't know when the front page is
live and yeah that's masted on code and
they're uh saying it's proprietary then
they're violent and all source code well
it's just wrong like what you need to
understand illegal no it isn't what
ian
if i said ian i own your coat is that
illegal
well if you're wearing it and walking
around town with it and i didn't give
you permission
yeah what do you mean it's just a copy
it's not the real thing right if if
source code says you cannot copy this
without like creative copy wait a minute
i thought you're the open the source guy
for big social networks yeah let's talk
about it a social network functioning in
the but not foreign it hasn't it's not
part of the commons yet if it becomes so
ubiquitous that no no ian you're wrong
he didn't steal anything it's a copy of
it if he copied gpl
code but you said copying isn't isn't
theft
it's not theft okay so what's the
problem he's violating the sort the
license no it's a copy
because it's the gpl license you can't
copy gpl license without crediting the
the original source code
ian's a guy who came out and said piracy
isn't theft because it's just a copy and
you're not taking the real thing and i
was making it trump copied it yeah
digital copying is not the same thing as
stealing someone's original
what huh sorry difficult to understand
ian you can't have both positions it
makes no sense yeah
i mean you're saying he's pirating the
software is that what you're saying sure
what's that that's not legal tim
okay
what we'll see i mean if it's are you
are you encouraging people to take gpl
code and make it private we don't know
if that's the case oh exactly we don't
know what exactly is going on and you
don't know uh as to what on the site
might be proprietary but you said it was
illegal and the point i'm making is that
like dude if i tell people that i own
your glasses i didn't commit a crime by
doing it yeah but if you're walking
around displaying that as your own then
you are he's not the site's not live
social.com is live right now oh it isn't
i just go i'm on it yeah you're not you
you pulled it up didn't you you i mean
you're not you know the login part might
not be my
because it's not here i thought you just
said it was they they got to you no i
said
yes but what i meant was people who
broke in searched the source code of the
social platform and found that mastodon
was listed on the actual site that's
live it doesn't say it as far as i know
but regardless regardless i know trump
is it probably doing something wrong i'm
going to wait until it goes live before
i start joining in on the on the
mainstream media the vomitorium
orange man bad narrative when you say go
live when when the front page is live
the site has gone live even if you can't
get in and log in yet the site is still
live
you're just trying you you try so hard
to like change
a social network i know what it means
you're you're fighting an allegation
made by the mainstream media against
donald trump when when the right
position in my opinion should be let's
just wait find out yeah i think you're
both right i think yeah i'm not i'm not
going to push the issue here maybe he
will let's just wait and find out i
think that's i just don't understand why
ian's mad about this i don't understand
it's important to me that if you use
free software code that you uphold the
license
well maybe they are maybe they have a
license how do you know if they don't
have a license in their terms they say
it's proprietary so maybe they have a
license yeah but there will be a
proprietary license that's not gps or
maybe
maybe they have a different agreement
with masternode we don't know yet
guys said he's gonna sue private
property
like i don't know then you thought wrong
but you had a huge argument about ip you
said copying isn't illegal it should be
allowed well i don't know if i didn't
say copying isn't illegal i said copying
and stealing are different you said
copying is okay it's not theft because
it's not the real i didn't say it's okay
either i said it's not stealing it's
different than stealing so piracy in the
old days was if a pirate would go to
your ship and take your stuff and you
don't have it anymore nowadays they make
a copy of it and they call it piracy but
it's different than that old school i
write a song and then someone copies it
and then shares it with a billion people
is that wrong
you could make that argument yeah do you
think it is wrong i mean
right and wrong aren't the words i would
use for it but it's definitely not the
way the system's built to be from well
that's the opposite of what you said you
know a couple weeks ago ian they're
really coming down and you know i got a
message from an anonymous source
on my instagram that said to tell ian to
shut up and i have a feeling that it was
tim that sent me that to be honest
no
it's hey i'm making bold claims and they
need to have holdings i'm defending you
i don't agree right
what i'm talking about is extremely it's
it's extremely jarring to the system so
we need people to punch holes in the
things i'm saying because i need to make
sure that what i'm saying is bulletproof
if i'm going to go forward with it
donald trump should not take open source
code and then lock it up and then
develop on top of it while restricting
access to it it's okay with open source
but not with free software like gpl it's
not open source code that's free
software code oh right so he's taking
freeware and then turning it into not
freeware free software licensing code
freeware is like uh diablo one yeah you
can go take for free
all right well let's talk about
something else something makes me feel
good
so uh i'm i'm browsing the old reddit
and i come across this post from a
subreddit called bye bye job
and i'm like yeah i wonder what this is
all about
well basically it's supposed to be a
subreddit where people who do bad things
and get fired get made fun of
all right kind of a negative thing you
know reddit loves bullies so as long as
it's okay with the establishment
bullying so i notice a whole lot of
these things are people who are like the
vaccine mandate is wrong i will not
abide by this and they're being mocked
and made fun of so i'm like i'm going to
scroll through this subreddit bye bye
job and wow the top post here my wife
was a doctor has been a doctor for 30
years kitty transplant specialist
emergency specialist hospitalist didn't
lose a covet patient patient has natural
immunity and will tomorrow see her last
day because science we stand to lose
everything she has ever worked for wow
remember when doctors were heroes they
put a clown face they put a clown face
no jab no job we will miss you hahaha
vaccine bad
then we have this one then we have this
one it's basically hero fiber i saw this
and they're like oh they also have the
sokatoa lady that was actually really
funny but i saw this and they're making
fun of all of these people who are like
i am standing up for what i believe in
and i'm just like
this is actually a white pill you know
it's like an optimistic
light all of these posts it's hard to
sing it's hard to believe when i see all
of these posts of people saying i will
not comply i'm like wow yeah maybe more
people than we realize look at orange
county battalion chief fired after he
didn't issue reprimands over vaccine
mandate raleigh's restaurant ordered to
remain closed over coveted
non-compliance
what is this one another youtube channel
got a strike or whatever i guess i don't
know ge aviation employees walk out over
vaccine mandate according to an employee
participating in the protest up to 75 of
staff did not show up for work at the
durham north carolina peebles ohio and
lafayette indiana locations wow that's
amazing that's great someone gets banned
or whatever and then nearly 1 900
washington state employees quit fired
over vaccine mandate assisted living
anti-vaccines fired for vaccine refusal
actor chad john kimball claims he lost
come from a way job over religion it's a
and they said they put vaccine bad on it
all of these posts i'm like yo if you
want to see hope for humanity go to r
bye bye job and cheer for these people
who are saying bye-bye job because
they're standing up for what they
believe in yeah i wonder how much of
that southwest thing triggered a lot of
that and with the in and out thing
happening and now you're seeing i don't
know how these are dated but i mean i
feel like something's happening right
now where you're actually able to see
that if you do actually stand up for
yourself things happen but it's got to
be a unified thing and that's always
been the problem is getting everybody to
on board but yeah i don't know i mean
this is interesting this isn't this
isn't organized i mean some of it is
clearly when 75 of workers don't show up
that's what i mean though but the
southwest thing i talked to a pilot and
he said that it's basically just
everybody realizing if i'm gonna get
fired i'm gonna use my sick time
it's like i might as well use my
vacation days while i still can
well it's illegal for them to officially
protest but it's also important to note
here that southwest lost an estimated 75
million dollars in the four days where
this alleged freedom flew was going
around and whether it's sick leave or
paid leave
you know it does show the disruptions
that these mandates are causing that are
dividing people to a point where a lot
of people are not working now you add
that to the supply chain shortages
you're asking for a disaster to happen
here because you're not going to have
enough workers for a lot of very
important tasks that need to be done
there and seeing all these people resist
and you know some people are deciding to
make fun of them but you made a good
point here there's a lot of them just
amazing and i've been talking about this
for a while the the perception of what
we see on on the mainstream media on big
tech social media is a perception that
obviously is ignoring
huge protests that are happening not
just all across the united states but
all over the world there's major huge
demonstrations with thousands of people
tens of thousands even in some instances
hundreds of thousands of people hitting
the streets saying enough is enough i am
not complying with your nonsense i'm not
going to be asking for permission for
from the government to go to the grocery
store i'm not going to do that i also
want to point out on this subreddit they
have uh real bryson gray he got a strike
on youtube for his song called let's go
brandon yes wow for uh i guess i said
medical misinformation
vaccine bad there was also some reports
about tick tock potentially going after
him as well i mean but the song let's go
brandon again in the top charts in in
many different platforms which shows you
the popularity of people saying hey i
you know this symbolic reference of
let's go brandon showing people's
discontent at the current administration
for what is obviously creating these
problems for everyone which will only be
exacerbated from here but you know
there's so many people and and they
don't want you to know that there's a
lot of these people you're finding out
about them through people making fun of
them but there's a lot more of them than
the mainstream media than social media
even lets on one of the one of the posts
seattle cops and firefighters feed
homeless after getting fired for
refusing vaccine i saw that story i see
it here and i'm like
heroes seriously still to this day wow
and the comments the top comment oh so
now the seattle cops give a crap about
the homeless i'm sure they always did
yes these people think that like cops
are like vampires or something like evil
monsters
well that's their narrative that was
sold to them on big tech social media
all cops are evil they're all bad and
wait here we go third comment wow it's a
good thing there were reporters there to
capture this selfless act probably a
lucky coincidence are you suggesting
that fox news colludes with police in
some sort of propaganda scheme
i will tell you exactly what happened
i'm willing to bet that some
firefighters and police
reached out to someone a reporter and
said we just want to let you know we're
going to be out feeding the homeless
it's going to be like a protest kind of
like an action and they went cool we'll
send someone down yeah this happens all
the time very shady yeah very shitty
there's even there's a conspiracy entire
restaurants uh there there's one in
california where the owner said that
only if you're unvaccinated you're
allowed if you're vaccinated you're not
allowed into his private restaurant in
california and that made a lot of news
headlines so so there's people even
flipping it on that level saying well if
you were discriminating against people's
medical choices i could do it as well i
don't believe in a kind of dude yeah
i was in california recently i i've
experienced that multiple places i mean
the second that i left the south that's
where i lived the second i got on the
plane there's been just nothing but
problems inconsistencies in the rules
and it's all coming from the top i mean
i was i was basically banned from coming
out here thank god i made it on the
plane but i mean i don't know if you
guys want to get into that but we'll get
into in a second yeah sure we got
another story though i'm just i'm just i
want to give people that beacon of hope
right 230 healthcare workers let go at
rwj barnabas virtua health for refusing
covid vaccine i mean this subreddit is a
plethora of people standing up for
themselves got placed on a suspension
from the school board because he refuses
to get the vaccine or get tested vaccine
bad 94 unvaccinated staff at yale new
haven health lose their jobs listen
i got no problem if you all want to go
to the doctor and you're concerned your
doctor says get the vaccine you say you
got it that's awesome that's that's
exactly what it's all about you and your
doctor and maybe maybe you got a bad
doctor you get a better one maybe you
got a good doctor maybe you got a doctor
like joe rogan got you talk to them you
say what's right here's my here's my
info they look at your history
when the government says if you want to
eat food if you want a job you've got to
abide by these rules that is new we've
never done anything like that that's
insane there's also websites popping up
showing
job boards for the unvaccinated that are
increasing in popularity with a lot of
people going on them and using them and
able to find employment when they were
just fired and lost a lot of their money
cool that's awesome yeah i feel like a
mainstream media really kind of gets off
on dividing conservatives and people who
don't think exactly like they do and i
think that this really is like tim said
a huge white pill because realizing that
you're not alone is incredibly powerful
like to see how many people are being
fired from health care places people who
work with vaccines nurses and doctors
saying no i'm not interested i don't
really want anything to do with that
that's kind of a white pill in itself
because then you're like okay i'm not
crazy maybe there's actually something
yeah isn't it funny how everybody was
worshiping the nurses and all the front
line workers and that now uh we're going
to fire you now i thought i thought we
needed i thought we were had a shortage
right what happened yeah well they work
with fear and intimidation and a lot of
the times a lot of these nurses aren't
even fired a lot of the front line
workers aren't even fired they're just
threatened and intimidated to a point
where they have to be
manipulated to get the shot some people
acquiesce some people do get the shot
but the people who stand up in some
cases do get to keep their jobs and the
mandates aren't implemented because
enough people did stand up to them looks
like there's about to be a bunch of
openings in baltimore baltimore police
union tells officers to not reveal
vaccine status that's interesting too
because that's not telling them not to
get it that means even if they did get
it they could still be in defiance of
the mandate and i'll tell you if there's
one city that needs police it's probably
baltimore so while these people are
laughing and cheering us on and mocking
these cops it's going to be a different
story when like they're walking home and
someone robs them and they're like i
don't understand why crime is going up
what's happening i forgot the name of
the police chief but there's a big
police district outside of chicago and
they open they recently said that
they're going to be hiring all the
police officers that get fired in
chicago and that they want to welcome
all of them to their uh new jobs just
you know a few miles away from chicago
so there's a lot of people actively
standing up actively speaking up
actively organizing and helping each
other out and that part of the story
isn't really
told
you know but i'm happy we're able to at
least talk about it that's right luke
truer words have never been spoken
do people still want to defund the
police or is that just oh yeah yeah they
still want to do that maybe so they
didn't see what happened in seattle when
they gave people
oh they liked that i mean in seattle
they they straight up murdered a couple
kids so they they liked them they
unloaded guns into a suv killing two
kids
who unloaded two black uh teenagers uh
adolescents that were shot and killed
uh it was this chas security saw a white
suv and were told that it was a white
supremacist so they saw it and they just
got down and they just
they said it was several hundred rounds
over 10 minutes and i think the kids
were like 13 or 14 years old i don't
remember it i don't remember exactly so
someone would have to fact check me but
they were very young children
and then what happened was the antifa
people immediately rushed the vehicle
and stripped all the evidence out yep
yep and then the police weren't able to
come in and the emts weren't able to
come in and then they got a suit over it
yeah they got sued for not going in
amazing yeah well let's let's talk about
what happened to you joey you got uh
so so you've got something you got put
on the no fly list because you're
because you're a dirty person yeah yeah
exactly they saw my youtube account
apparently but you know it's funny man
it's like so i had a trip out in l.a i
had to go out out to l.a for a wedding
and some business i get on the plane now
mind you i live in the south we don't
have any mandates down there i knew i
had to get on a plane i knew i had to
wear a mask so i go to the dollar store
on my way to the i almost forgot that i
had to wear a mess so i just stopped at
the dollar store i get one of those
gator wraps okay i get one of those you
know i don't know what you need on there
but i got through the the security line
i i got checked in i get on the plane an
hour into the flight somebody you know
they're doing announcements though and
this lady's waving a little package with
a mask in and she's just dangling it
over me and i go oh maybe they're just
giving me another one so i i didn't know
and apparently 20 minutes later this
lady comes up to me and she looks like
the jigglypuff meme have you ever seen
that the lady throw in the temper
tantrum
so she comes if you can imagine that she
comes up to me and she's pointing a
finger at me she goes mr borrelli you
agreed to the terms and i'm like hold
hold on we go who are you like she's
leaning over somebody's chair and she's
pointing like oh who are you talking to
like this why are you pointing your
finger why are you yelling at me and she
goes do you want them to turn a plane
around like well i just want to
understand what the hell is going on
here and he should go and i was like
what do you mean turn the plane around
why don't you ask everybody else
plane around right now yeah they're like
nazis i mean literally that's literally
you could hear the whole plane could
hear this i mean she's so aggressive i
have no idea what the hell is going on
she goes you agreed to wear the approved
uh diaper on your face or whatever they
call it so and i'm like well i don't
know i'm like how did i get through
screening how did i get how did i even
get on the plane it's an hour into the
flame like i don't even i don't even
understand what you're talking about and
she goes well you want us to you're
going to be inconvenienced you're going
to be inconveniencing people when we
turn the plane i don't know you're going
to be inconveniencing people i'm like i
don't want the plane to be turned around
and why don't you survey everybody and
she goes well we'll see about that and
she literally stormed off like like a
disney character like just stormed off
like a little baby right 20 minutes into
the i'm just sitting there and the guy
next to me is like i can't believe this
happened i can't either on the con on
the speaker on the cockpit i hear an
announcement he goes uh
sorry to bother you everybody this is
the uh this is the captain in the
cockpit um here we're we have a
passenger who's uh refusing to comply to
the mandates uh we're going to divert
the plane to memphis tennessee we're
probably going to lose an hour or so so
we apologize we're going to make it as
fast as possible and then and then the
jigglypuff comes back up to my scene she
goes that was for you and i go good how
much are graceland tickets because i
never been before i'd like to check it
out so now everybody's laughing on the
plane and she's getting pissed off right
then the gestapo shows up and out i'm
about almost an hour from la now the
gestapo shows up and they're all sitting
there like the little rascals the jiggly
puffs behind behind the guy who's the
gestapo like it's the whole squad like
six agents show up it's right like
flight attendants
yeah yeah so they're all pointing
fingers i'm like what is what point in
the fingers i go i don't understand i
was like can you tell me the difference
between this mask and that mask and they
go you agreed i'm like i understand but
i'm like i'm just trying to figure i'm
just trying to have a conversation i'm
like is it protocol to just point your
fingers at people and start yelling at
them i'm like we could have a civilized
conversation but like the fact that
you're just nasty i mean like what
airline was it
american airlines stalin airlines
apparently if i was wearing a joseph
stalin mask maybe it would have been
fine but this was not an anti-mask thing
and just to clear it up i'm not
anti-mask i'm anti you or anybody
telling me how to manage my health i
think that should be my personal
decision or i should rephrase force me
well so okay so what ends up happening
so what ended up happening was that they
gave me a piece of paper that says if
this uh if this experience heightens or
if there's something more happens you
know if you know if i start bucking the
system more then you will be greeted
with a person um in the airport and and
you know and they'll probably find me or
ban me or whatever but it never said
that i was banned i had the paper and so
sure enough nothing happened and i go to
check in today to get out here and sure
enough they go oh well you didn't comply
and i go well this was already resolved
and i was handed a warning they're like
no they said that they sent you an email
that you're banned from american
airlines i'm like well i never got that
and i go and i never not complied like i
couldn't even have a conversation i
tried for four hours to have a
conversation with these people but well
we'll have to you're gonna have to call
customer service and i'm like i'm
looking at it she had a cut i mean
that's what i'm talking i was at the
airport for two hours and she goes well
you gotta call i go see this is the
problem like nothing ever adds up
everything's inconsistent i finally get
the manager the manager finally comes
and then she goes will you comply and i
go you could have just said this in the
beginning i'm like of course i never not
wanted to comply i go but i look i grew
up in new york if somebody comes up to
you on the street they say the words
comply yes they said you did not comply
they said and they said that that's what
it's about yeah under the boot
yeah take the blue pill why didn't they
literally give you a mask on the plan
they tried to in the beginning they gave
it to me but at the time when that lady
gave it to me she didn't say anything
and i thought it was an extra one
because i didn't know at the time that
you needed an approved mask i didn't
know there was any different i've flown
before
during the pandemic and i remember
wearing a bandana and all this i didn't
know what changed because mind you i
live in the south we don't where i live
we don't have mandates so we just you
know we think that we've moved on from
but once you get on that plane you get
out there you know not a lot of states
have moved forward so i understand the
federal law and i like i said i even
went to the store to get the damn mask i
wasn't trying to be anti-mass or
anything like that but they they had me
boxed in as if i was and they're saying
i wasn't complying i'm like
i told you i grew up in new york it's
like somebody points a finger at you and
starts yelling it's like i don't want to
have a conversation like have some like
you're violating the civil obedience you
know what i mean it's like like b is a
civil human being i don't understand
this aggression that people have it's
almost like a religion like a cult and
like they think they're doing so like
just okay i didn't understand why don't
you treat me like a human being you're
talking about like a dog they talk to
you like a dog people have gone insane
this is something that we've noted
at some point
something happened where everyone just
became vile yeah
civility in any capacity i'm not talking
about politics i'm not talking about
uh you know discussing religion or money
you know the three things i say you're
not supposed i'm talking about
all of a sudden
gradually then suddenly people i knew
who used to be like hey you see the new
episode of you know whatever show and i
bet oh cool now they message me being
like this is some stupid fa and they're
yelling and they're angry their message
i get message on facebook and they're
just pissed off about everything and i'm
like why are you so mad
calm down don't tell me to calm down you
have no idea i'm like dude
you know what i don't i got locked in
they got locked in their cubicles and
their concrete blocks smelling like sour
milk these big cities exactly for a year
exactly
i'm passionate about stuff too but i
don't get worked up i don't get angry
like that i mean somebody sent me a
message the other day and they said that
that i'm an upset donnie wahlberg on
valium which i think is a i guess it's
an accurate
i mean i just don't get excited i don't
get excited like that you know what i
mean to to yell i mean like and what
does it cost really to take people's
civil liberties away your salary you
know what i mean is that all it calls
you i mean these these people are being
used to be soldiers for for an idea that
half of them don't even believe in
you know what i mean they do and that's
that's the scary thing when you look in
their eyes and you see that like they're
doing something i'm like you're gone
like this is how so here's the funny
thing right
this is how nazi germany happens now i'm
not saying it's identical history
doesn't repeat it rhymes what i'm saying
is when i make comparisons to what we're
seeing now in the united states with the
conflict the split the cult
people say i'll say like you know civil
war tensions spanish civil war weimar
germany and they'll say oh it's not like
the nazi germany blah blah blah i'm like
not yet
so did you think that when it came to
like the spanish civil war one day
everyone woke up and said guess i'll go
fight my neighbor
no there were tensions brewing for a
long time weimar jeremy you think people
just woke up one day and said i really
don't like that group of people no it
was a long period of time where they
kept doing things and it was increment
after increment after increment right
but we look at history and it's
condensed we say and this year this
happened and then all of a sudden you
get this and it's like dude right now we
are seeing
you you see these videos right where the
woman's sitting at the table and they're
screaming black lives matter and they
get in her face and they hold their
fists to her face like it is it is
psychotic mob yeah who does that remind
you of
the term look at what happened with
netflix outside of netflix yeah when you
got the guy holding the sign saying we
like dave so they attack him
steal the sign destroy it then claim
he's got a weapon get in his face
screaming shaking a tambourine yelling
repent i heard his video was taken down
on twitter as well
yeah for copyright claims but this is
what happens when you have such
psychological abuse that has been
represented in the mainstream media
showing you grandma's gonna die
grandma's gonna die it's gonna be
horrible people are gonna suffer but you
could stop it if you're just enough of a
karen and they give people a little bit
of authority that little bit of
authority goes to their head but they're
psychologically thinking that they're
doing the right thing that being tough
on you as a little peasant slave as a
little peon as a little person that is
supposed to obey everything the
government
decrees
that they're in the right because
they're going to save lives by doing
this when in reality
that is further from truth than i think
a lot of people people i think people
get power over i think it's like you're
giving people that typically don't have
power power the everyday person that
works at the store or the flight
attendant where it's like they get off
on it because they don't have that power
typically so when they're they're handed
that power look what they do with it i
mean that's why we do have issues with
cops in a way that that abuse their
power and stuff it's like to give a
citizen a badge and a gun or a power
over somebody it's like you it proves
that you they don't it's hard to find
good help obviously because there's no
there's not a good enough screening
press nobody should be pointing their
finger at their mind you this one was a
hundred pounds overweight i'm not trying
to fat shame here but like i don't think
that she was really that concerned about
her health to be honest with but she's
she's acting like it is the mask is the
wrong word
vaccine is the wrong word mandate is the
right word comply
comply you know and here's the thing
if you're rich you don't got to comply
no you can get a private plane you got
to worry about it you get a private car
you don't got to worry about it you
don't got to adhere to any of these
rules and if you're really rich you
don't even need passports right like
billionaires when they fly into
countries they don't need passports yeah
what was that of an event with the
celebrities the met gal or that was the
with the what's her name but you know
it's like it's what do they say right
rules for for thee but not for me i mean
it's it is what it is you can't expect
celebrities to have to abide by rules
the rich they're better than you and
they know it and people don't see that
and they and they still knock guys like
us you know that that are able to break
that spell it's all in front of our face
right now when people became vile
and you know i'd see somebody on
facebook and their comments would just
be like this thing is making me really
angry and i'm furious and they're stupid
and this slur and that slur
that rage
well when they're at their job and
they're flipping burgers and you walk in
and you're not abiding by the rules
now's their chance to get their anger
out there's a video where a guy is
chasing a woman who's not wearing a mask
and he says does anybody else think it's
wrong that we all have to wear masks and
she isn't
and she's like get away and the people
are like get away from her dude like
calm down yeah i mean that's a perfect
representation of what's going on
psychologically in everyone's head that
you pinpointed very well there tim
because
again i still can't understand but but
when i do
i i can't understand when i hear stories
about what happened to you it's hard to
fathom because it's just weird to
understand that people could be so mean
and rude to each other but then when you
do look at what a lot of these people
are are fed on social media when you
look at the rage bait when you look at
the echo chambers that are just
regurgitated on them 24 7 that they
can't escape
um you could see this kind of
indoctrination being laid on very thick
very heavily and it indoctrinates these
people to double down triple down on
these kind of larger ideas that they are
the ones that are going to save everyone
yeah by policing everyone and and that's
a delusional belief that's absolutely
very dangerous and it's it's the same
idea that was used in germany it's the
same idea that was used in communist
ussr
countries it was the same ideologies
used by many dictators by many despots
all throughout history because they know
if they could psychologically
manipulate someone to believe that
they're doing the right thing
but at the end of the day they're
serving their purposes they're going to
do it willingly and their agenda their
narrative is going to be rammed through
as quickly as it can this is what uh
gina carano was trying to make as a
point and she lost her i mean she didn't
lose her career but like you know i mean
like she lost a big opportunity there
yeah she's not gonna be saying don't
demonize your neighbor yeah and she's
not gonna be in season two yeah she's
one of the good guys she made that exact
point that that you brought up to him
that i kind of expanded on a little bit
she made that exact point and she got
cancelled and kicked out of a major
series
uh
for even mentioning with all the actors
even standing by being like wait what
she was a major part of the series why
can't she come back
why because she's she's speaking about
things that absolutely make perfect
sense well how about we go to super
chats if you haven't already smash that
like button send your super chats we'll
be reading a bunch of your comments
don't forget to share this video and go
to timcast.com because we're gonna have
that members only segment coming up so
sign up become a member and uh saturday
saturday is that live event ryan long is
going to be there uh there might be a
bunch of special guests because
you know we're friends a lot of people
who are in the dc area who have big
followings and maybe they'll be there as
well i'm not going to say anybody but
you might be like i can't believe the
people who have shown up something's
very big well more than one person yeah
we're talking to a few people who are
like yeah i'll come hang out we're like
dude this is going to be big so uh
that's why it's so so important to be a
member at timcast.com because these
tickets were free for everybody who is a
member at 25 bucks or more and we're
planning on doing these events
at least once a month it'll be a little
tricky with the holidays coming up we
were trying to do it earlier in the year
but next year it's going to be crazy
especially with us building out freedom
stand we're gonna build a stage we're
gonna have our own massive acreage it'll
be very complicated but uh we're gonna
we're gonna get rolling on this stuff so
thanks for being members everybody and
for those that got tickets we'll see you
saturday and if you haven't there there
there are auctions i think we have six
tickets left we're two tickets per
auction and you can just bid
and then it's like for a day and then if
you win you get to come and hang out so
yeah all right let's read
gibson says dwack to the moon if you
voted for biden and bought dwack today
welcome to the trump train this could
have been the economy the last eight
months
punk's not dead says hundred thousand
what a year to drive a rig on track to
make 150 000 this year without the pay
increase wow
crazy
all right let's see
westfield 90 says tim 99 wrong on your
predictions just yesterday said the
house would not vote on steve bannon
obstruction charge today they voted and
passed it oh wait the the the the full
house floor voted for it
i'm not sure i have one paying attention
to that story to be honest
and nine republicans no no the full
house floor i don't know
can someone google it i can look it up
so what happened was the they say uh
today they voted and passed it maybe
it's a democrat uh controlled house so
the committee voted to seek criminal
prosecution of bannon but we were all
like the floor that's not gonna it's not
gonna pass we're still waiting for the
doj to decide if they're gonna press
charges i think that's the stuff that's
where they're at right now the committee
passes the resolution yeah then it goes
to a floor vote if it passes the floor
vote it'll be sent to the doj did it
pass 19 minutes ago house votes to hold
trump ally steve bannon in contempt
so we were wrong about that
i don't think it's better to say 99
wrong because we didn't think we're they
were going to try and arrest steve
bannon on this one but wow okay
it's worse than i realized as he's about
to release his interview with jeffrey
epstein
it is it is worse than we realize man
all right matthew velasquez says i'm a
trucker d uh d-a-t load board showing
8.99 reefer loads for monday and brokers
are already offering 12 dollar loads and
have been for over a month pray
i don't know what that means
hey i just got did you guys know gina
carano's uh daily wire movie got
cancelled two days ago no live we were
just working on it i'm looking at this
is we got this covered.com never heard
of it but apparently tied to her anti
according to this article anti-vaxx
beliefs what they're struggling to
square shooting a movie with the looming
federal government
the daily wire came out and said they
will not comply with any vax mandate
this is uh gina carano recently revealed
that she cancelled a movie over the
strict kova 19 vaccine and mandates this
is from bounding into the blast gina
chrono finds bounding into the blast
yeah i'm just looking at it
you try and find some some better
sources i'll come back i can't well look
i'll i'll certainly accept it's possible
for sure but i can't imagine the daily
wire it was it was jeremy boring right
yeah and he came out and he was like we
will not comply with joe biden
mandate
well i don't know we'll see i really
don't uh believe that could be true
all right peter gunn says luke i'm in
florida and want to buy more shirts
could you please offer more in a color
other than black my favorites are only
available in black no only black uh and
white sometimes white uh but i think i'm
gonna offer that to uh
people on luke uncensored some some
crazy wild different shirts so that
might be available there but it's just
simple it's just a lot easier to make
one graphic for one particular color uh
i you know you got to pay graphic
artists for every new design for all
that so it's just more cost effective so
it's just easier to do it for me that
way little tails farm says hey tim thank
you for the idea of chicken coop indoor
plumbing so to say in chicken city i'm
going to build something of the sort in
chicken town and i owe the idea to you
my fellow chicken bro oh so chicken city
we're estimated to be done tomorrow we
have a massive chicken coop this is the
one percent of chickens i mean it's a
chicken fortress
and what they what what our construction
guys have built is beneath where the
chickens sleep because they dump like
crazy in their sleep there is a plastic
basin that rolls down into gutters which
funnel out and just go off kind of like
a septic leech field essentially i saw
that didn't you post that on your
instagram or you i saw the inside of the
coop yeah is that what i don't i don't
think we've shut we showed the full
gutter so they actually buried pipes
underneath
and they go down and so when it rains
yeah or if we take the hose out we just
run the hose and it flushes it all out
and then it just spits it out
into the muck in the mire
keep got to keep it clean got to keep it
clean and we're going to be building a
luxury insulated little area for the
winter for them we're going to do like
ply board foam ply board and make a
really nice you know insulator thing i
don't think we need to do it too much
some people have said you know get a
heater or whatever but i've seen a lot
of people saying that basically the
chickens can stay warm if they're just
in an enclosed space what are you going
to do for the the predators digging into
the ground no that goes two feet
underground ah yeah good good we have uh
uh yeah so definitely not gonna get in
and then we also have dogs around i got
some info from the daily wire and
apparently they're working on a carano
movie called white based on a thriller
novel called white knuckle that they had
to furlong they had to stop because
something to do with the vaccines now
they're working on a different project
with her called terror on the prairie so
it's it sounds like maybe contractors or
other other states or something weren't
allowed it probably has to do with like
the 100-person vaccine i'm hearing
delayed because of fed mandates huh
that's what i'm hearing i don't know if
it's true and the name of it is daily
wire releases details on new gina chrono
project terror on the prairie that's
from daily wire i imagine what this
means is that the daily wire is not
doing anything to gina chrono it's that
let's say if you're trying to put a
movie together and you're like we're
going to go film in georgia and then
georgia says we have this rule and
you're like oh no yeah so if they had to
film in new york but new york is like
vaccine mandates you're like hey how are
we going to film this and then people
use toronto often or chicago and they
got mandates too
change the movie let's shoot it in the
outback in the wilderness it's uh
yeah this is actually here's a quote
from uh daily wire with the
precariousness of the current hollywood
landscape and the remarkable overreach
by its ruling class we made the tough
prudent choice to ride further out into
the wild west and make movies on our own
terms
and that was i don't know who said that
it says he said i'm not sure they
probably had uh they probably had
contractors who were doing vaccinated
yeah
and you know our company is over 100
employees see this is why we need our
own countries we need to split up the
regions i'm telling you like the west
coast could have all this crap they can
indoctrinate their kids they could
identify as aliens and just leave the
normal people to where they want to be
because it's like this kind of stuff you
can't you're preaching to luke yeah i've
been talking about that for like a year
plus i'm not with you about a divorce
i want to talk to you about it we'll
talk about this also this comment was
from producer dallas sonier i think
that's the way you pronounce his last
name the guy that was producing it
all right let's read some more
michael scott cutler says manhattan
grocery shops are fully stocked pumpkins
toilet paper you name it no shortages
here yet and actually today
at the supermarket it was stocking day
so everything seemed fine it's i think
it's more like target when you're
looking for
uh certain specific goods like dressers
pillows
tables chairs we went to we were trying
to get a couch for the studio
and uh instead we got papazons because
they didn't have it we couldn't find any
so we were like we need to get like a
small couch and they're like you can
order it maybe it'll show up did papa
john's give you the papa john's papa and
so we went to uh walmart and they were
like the only thing we have is a caramel
colored futon and gray papazons and i
was like i am putting a caramel colored
futon in here so we got the papazons but
you know i like them better honestly
they're way more comfy yeah curl up get
a book it's great
all right hexmare says ian you mentioned
being interested in radiocalms a couple
weeks back if you are still interested i
am more than willing to uh more than
willing on getting you all on the path
to worldwide communications over the air
yeah weren't we going to do a ham radio
or something i would love to we should
oh yeah the zeppelin's coming yeah in a
couple weeks
yeah so um
the zeppelin is coming wikipedia will be
forced to issue a correction
so the story is that wikipedia once
claimed i invented a zeppelin when i
didn't
so then you know i said ian let's do the
zeppelin and he's like okay so now we
actually have the zeppelin so now
wikipedia who lied about me and then
later had to remove it we'll not have to
put it back i thought they can't write
their own stuff though no they they they
used a source that was like
a bad source
and they were like but it says it's
reliable that means it's true i love how
absolutely dumb wikipedia is just like
it is it is such utter garbage yeah and
didn't you say that it's not true and
they're like you're not a reliable
source
i remember being like guys i never
invented this i'm like we can't trust
you you're not reliable but but what
that means is an individual cannot be a
source for themselves right it's got to
be awful to be a public figure and have
that come up as the first as your google
search when it's like it's just chaos
and it's like you got all these lies on
there it's like and what do you even do
to even get that stuff removed i mean
what kind of loot
oh she got it i mean through the the so
i will say
it's really fascinating we went when we
bought when we were buying free damastan
the agent was very apolitical and she
was like oh i looked up your your wiki
and i was like well it's all it's all
it's mo it's like half not true right
like that's what i mean it says i voted
for ron paul in 2008.
ron paul wasn't the primary uh candidate
in 2008 i voted for obama in 2008. they
just someone wrote a story about me they
maybe misconstrued uh who i voted for in
the 2008 presidential election
ends up in a news story in a spanish
source or i think it was a venezuela or
no chilean source and then that's the
source they use when there are other
sources where it's like tim poole voted
for obama to this nate support bernie
sanders in 2016. yeah it's amazing if
you're right-wing or something like
you're automatically a nazi on there
it's like how do you get that taken down
it says tim poole's audience is largely
right-wing see what i mean and then in
the talk section people are like what's
the source on this how is this true and
they're like some op-eds claimed it
and they're like good enough for us and
i'm like we actually did a poll it was
mostly libertarian
like like non-descript libertarian not
right-wing libertarian
just people saying they cared about
freedom and liberty yeah they must work
with the fact checkers but but i will
say after that was trump supporters and
then after that was was liberals
actually liberals were really large a
decently large portion i think it's like
20 or so percent then like trump
supporters were like 30 and then
libertarian was the biggest and then
there was like social justice warrior
leftist self-identified and stuff like
that i found that really together
i don't know i there are a lot of people
who uh hate watch to the person that
sent me that super chat about the ham
radio can you message me on twitter and
uh i want to go back and forth with you
and find the best ham radio
yeah we'll go from there all right
western canadian commentary says thanks
tim and crew for all you do been a
member on timcast.com for a while surely
to god someone in the democrat party is
a necromancer how else do you explain
biden pelosi my money is on the cackling
camelot
nightingale mori says every time tim
said bitcoin war shortage or whatnot
i've always i've always been hey should
i invest be safe then i realize that i'm
a week behind all of my news the crap i
need triples in price
[Music]
yeah people don't like it there are some
people that really don't like it when i
shout out safeandreadymeals.com which is
that is not a promo but they don't like
i shouted it out today in a segment it's
emergency food
some there's one emergency food supply
that you can't get anymore because
they're out
and so i'm like yo when they're talking
about all this stuff
make an investment yourself you know
what i'll tell you this get a magnifying
glass you know i ordered a bunch of
magnifying glasses you know what
light some fires if you need to and
you're out camping and you're with your
friends you want to get a fire going you
get a major same with these crystal
balls i think wizards in the past they
said they could throw fireballs but they
would actually hold up crystal balls and
light stuff on fire from a distance
maybe yeah yeah and you can also use a
bag of water you can use a bottle of
water or a baggie with water in it and
then you can use it to focus light
i think we're doing that's really good
man i think you're building a nice
little homestead here i've always been a
big uh you know pushing you know
avoiding babylon is what i always say is
anything you could do to avoid having to
rely on babylon like going to the
grocery store if you could grow your own
crops i mean you got chickens and this
and that i mean like i think this is
really the way to do it because if
you're going to be under the rule of of
babylon you i mean you could see i
barely made it out here i mean like
maybe if i walk in a grocery store i'd
have a problem i don't know but it's not
out here yes i don't even know what i'm
getting into well here but what happens
in d.c
nightmare yeah i'm not going to be there
so what we got we got a good one here
this is from i am insanity says been
watching since 2015 with timcast.com for
about a year and have been stocking up
since january 2020 thanks to you tim
there we go when we had the freeze in
texas i was able to feed me and my
family now stocked up for six months and
you gotta understand six months is not
that much
so i'm not telling anybody to go break
the bank i'm not saying fill up a secret
room in your basement full of like
massive you know 500 buckets of beans
and rice or anything like that i'm
saying like these buckets you get like
two of them and it's good for like one
person for two weeks and it's it's like
80 bucks for like a bucket and then if
there's a flood if there's rain or
whatever that's all i'm saying people
people go through the roof with this
because they're like they what luke
what's this look on your face i'm saying
storage containers i'm saying buy them
out
put them in there bullets firearms
storable food all you need to get and uh
with luke man yeah that's yeah i'm not
saying the grid's going down guys at
some point i'm not saying don't prep
yeah i'm saying
it'd be reasonable i'll tell you this
though when when when the bad stuff goes
down do you think the prepper cares that
you're making fun of him
no you're gonna show up to his door
being like you have food i would like
something that's good everyone's gonna
come to your house the preppers were we
don't have any we're probably we should
probably get more yeah you know we
recently bought uh uh we got a big
pallet of water but that's usually
because we said for guests when they
drink bottled water but now we're doing
our own glass bottles and our own double
purified
double nine stage filter uh well water
with minerals added into it in glass
bottles so you don't get leaching we're
doing better if you're getting into the
water game i'm getting into the kool-aid
game and i'm gonna have luke radowski's
kool-aid available
that's okay
grind up some raspberries
all right let's see evan hogan says
weird i did not see any safe and ready
meals yes i am a card-carrying
libertarian for years now uh it was in
one of my videos
safe and readymills.com not trying to
shout them out but you know if you learn
about it
uh i just think it's crazy to me that
people in cities mock the idea of
knowing how to defend for yourself but
it makes sense right conservatives
moderates libertarians tend to be like
okay i got to have some responsibility
for myself right if you're a
collectivist you're like why would i
bother having a weapon for my defense or
knowing how to start a fire yeah why
would i want to do any of that meanwhile
their whole existence in these cities
are relying on the people that live the
life that you're talking about they rely
on the truck drivers to provide them for
food that are living off of the land
what happens when that goes out what
happens when the lights go out and the
grocery stores then what then they'll be
like i said they'll be coming out here
but it's just
yeah it's just funny how those people
have that attitude but everything's done
for them i always say like living in the
city is you couldn't be far further
removed from god and when i say god it's
of anything that's natural of the earth
anything that benefits you it's all
artificial the joke we have is that we
had before was that you know you're
going to be out in the middle of nowhere
with some chickens minding your own
business and you're going to hear
rustling outside and the wife's going to
be like honey i hear an animal it might
be a bear and he's like i'm going to get
the shotgun and then he goes outside and
there's like a new york hipster guy yeah
grabbing the chicken and biting into it
like i'm so hungry and then he runs with
it and you're like jeez yeah
tick-tocking's not gonna help in that
situation have you seen these videos
of uh oh it's your video where you where
you got all these people tick-tocking in
the streets and it's the creepiest thing
yeah i drove in la and i almost ran over
one there was a guy tick-tock
in the street in a crosswalk
and so so i i remember i saw this um in
our in our last studio in in the philly
area i remember looking out the window i
was like walking through to the kitchen
and i see this little girl in the street
just like dancing and doing this weird
thing yeah and then i'm like what the
what is she doing and then she walks up
to her mailbox and picked her phone up
and i was like
oh she's tick tock dancing yeah
meanwhile she's probably got a million
views meanwhile there's a guy like
leonardo da vinci out there probably
with 300 followers probably like it's
like you just wake up at the end of your
bed and twirl your arms and you're a
celebrity now it's sad it works all
right let's read some more we got dukko
darling says where can i get luke's
necklace
um this was a gift i've i forgot where i
got that that was really cool from a
shaman in brazil i got it in florida
miami
i have some crystals that are from like
very weird crazy stories in peru and
south america and africa but just not
this this is just uh from miami let's go
sacred geometry
american advocate says michael malus on
glenn beck what a beautiful mind i'm on
board the libertarian train republicans
too soft and democrats well we all know
michael malus just did a press tour he
was on glenn beck he was on rogan and i
tell you
leave it to malice one guy that can get
rogan to spark up a joint
in the middle of the conversation he
will take him there who else did too
elon musk elon got him too well i think
joe is the one who initiated that yes
yeah michael was the one that took joe
to a place where he's like i gotta get
stoned for this wow you guys gotta watch
that episode it's fantastic all right
donna rose says it seems that everything
that people valued or brought them
self-worth for the last 50 years has
been slowly demoralized it's almost as
if we are being manipulated to hate
ourselves it would be easy to manipulate
people if so new world order may be oh
it is so easy to manipulate pieces what
we were talking about earlier
it's in
look if manipulation wasn't a thing they
wouldn't buy commercials yeah ads work
and you know a lot of ads you know you
know what i really hate
i hate when i'm like watching a show and
then also there's a commercial and it's
like a guy's riding his bike and then he
crashes his bike and then he gets up and
then a woman pulls up in her car and
she's like whoa take a spill and he's
like yeah and it's like rich's chicken
pick up something today and i'm like
what the [ __ ] that i have to do anything
nothing you know i love like head-on
remember that commercial head-on
directly to the forehead
i'm like i get it it was easy thank you
i still remember it you see
commercials in my opinion
like they don't got to be so boring
where it's a guy who walks someone's
like hi this is soda it tastes good buy
arsenal that would work though
there's an opening i saw that commercial
they have that i forgot which company
did it um yeah but see i would buy that
just because of that yeah it's true i
would like it if a guy was like hello i
sell cheeseburgers my stores yeah rich's
cheeseburger shop i think about that all
the time didn't they kind of do that in
the 50s in a way it was very simple like
here is a product that i would like to
show like that that would get me more i
feel like there's just an opening to go
back to that now now it's like the
commercial comes on we're trying we're
trying to guess what it's for and then
it's like people holding hands and
singing on the beach then it shows a
rainbow and a bird flies over and it
hovers above everybody and we're like is
it going to be an anti-depressant
no nope it's a constipation commercial
yeah yeah
yeah well that's the way it goes huh
all right let's see we got here
we'll grab a super chat
steve may says remember when ian was
against iprites pepperidge farmer
members uh just poking at you ian great
show tonight everyone and great guest ae
there you go
all right yeah we had a bunch of
interesting comments on gpl where
everyone was saying ian was wrong so i
definitely want to read those give it to
me
all right jc drop shot says tim your
shipping money estimate is off in the
fish industry containers are going for
over 33 000 in shipping costs
we expect the cost to rise above 45 000
mid next year okay what you got to do
you got to dig a bigger hole in your
backyard put some liner in it then you
got to buy some salmon you got to put it
in there and then you got to buy food
and hopefully you'll have a your own
supply of fresh farmed salmon for a long
time because you're not going to get
them from the stores
all right justin clybacker says this is
just so i can hear you mispronounce my
last name a few times kleebicker
clybacker oh gosh playa backer i tried
all right let's see
how much did he pay for that for you to
do that 50 bucks he should ask he should
have asked me i'm great at that
gimple says ian is 100 right about the
software licensure he actually knows the
difference with regards to the formats
stop ganging up on him not a good look
not a good not a good look but it's a
good conversation to have you know
all right h music says ian piracy is not
theft music should be downloaded for
free with no consequences also ian
copying code is illegal and should have
consequences
uh when other people make quotes of you
out of context
[Laughter]
mindfully says sorry ian is just flat
wrong read the actual license github
mastodon click agpl
interesting
all right let's see i want i want to
read the specific ones about the gps
this is trump social network it's
interesting uh s
blight uh uh sb lights out there you go
ian just yelled that he built a network
like joe biden was yelling there are
fewer not more fewer all right yeah i
wasn't the only one involved with that
but i was there from the beginning and
guided the process
j s failer says ian was ian is 100
correct about open source licenses it's
not about copying it's about breaking a
legally binding agreement when you use
the software i i know and when you
download someone's song and then
distribute it by copying it you're also
violating the license yeah so i'm trying
to build a technological solution to the
whole piracy scheme i don't like calling
it piracy i think that the fbi might be
using that as an excuse to go hard on
people that are copying data like
they're sea pirates
but i think that if you can somehow i
can go into it if you want but
code it into the into the software where
if it gets sold or repurposed that the
original creator also gets the majority
of the of the sale value a new kind of
license like creative commons but like
one up yeah you can use this for
commercial purposes with the 10 royalty
to the creator or like 99 goes to the
creator you get one percent for selling
it and then you'll have people form like
websites where they'll be aggregating
and selling content getting one percent
of all but all the money will really be
going to the people that created it
all right the commander says i agree
with ian you can use software and make
money off of it as long as you pay for
access to it or it's free eg how many
games used the original doom engine or
were made with rpg maker and sold it's a
thing that happens tim it's not piracy
no i think you're confused i agree with
that that if trump took you know open
source code and made something with it
he can use it ian's saying it's free
software not open source
so uh and then
in regards to copying content what i'm
saying is if i write a song and then
sell that song digitally and then
someone copies it and gives it out to
for free to millions of people they
stole from me and they stole quite a bit
but i mean i'll say this about my music
because i have one song public available
by all means copy download distribute
give it away to everybody
we are selling it
you can actually be great if everybody
was sharing you can change the license
on the youtube video to become creative
commons and then they'll be able to do
it without and then people can take it
break it down and then make remixes as
long as they give credit to the original
all right let's see we got here
matthew velasquez says trucker's
chanting let's go brandon on the cb
radio today all throughout tennessee
this happens every day now wow people
know what it means man
jay schartzer says you can use gpl
privately with no restrictions i.e
corporations can use new cash for
accounting changes when you propagate
the work and make changes
interesting
little balau says thoughts on bank of
international settlements and esgs also
ian is awesome much love
that's uh what what does esg
i'm gonna leave this to you
it's the corporate social credit score
essential social governance looking at
this easier earlier today esg corporate
uh yeah jack pacific brought up the
other day oh it's key it's it's the one
of the main kind of larger octopuses
that are calling the shots with its
tentacles and environmental social and
governance yep and it's it's literally a
corporate social credit score um jack
vasobic went into it pretty heavily last
night so check out the show from last
night if you want to hear it it's very
important very influential
steve otten says getting into ham is a
must for for damastan if the system and
infrastructure collapse ham will be the
only way to communicate long range and
um i don't know if we talked about this
but i knew somebody was talking about
what is it called um
internet overham there's a there's a oh
yeah we talked what's that ben ben might
have been talking about a little bit a
long time ago my friend was talking
about it there's there is a phrase for
it there's it's like something over ham
radio
and uh you know like
koham or something but the idea was to
use multiple frequencies to send uh low
bit rate data kqed i don't know i don't
know
k-q-e-d a-r-r-l i have no idea i'm
looking into it no no it's like
something it's like ham you know ham
stands or something doesn't it
high-altitude something is that what it
is i wish i knew more about this google
what does ham mean people comment you
tell us what ham means right high
altitude is that what it means
all right let's see we'll read some more
han i can't read your name but it said
ham radio make sure to get a license
before using and realize old school
analog forms of communication are
definitely monitored oh of course you're
sure
admire says
i'm going to start a career as a tim
pool reply guy i don't have a twitter
yet wish me luck oh there's a bunch of
them it's funny like no matter what i
say they'll disagree with i could say
something like universal healthcare is
good and they'll be like you're a
grifter that's stupid and i'll be like
okay
i guess
all right cooterpunch911 says this is
excuse me i love the usernames we can't
repeat that
could you address the 125 million being
allotted to gain of function up to and
including ebola scott horton versus bill
kristoff and trump voice tremendous i
haven't uh seen that specifically i'll
have to look into that i suppose
ham radio mesh network just amateur
amateur radio bryson gray super chatted
have you heard have you mentioned me
getting banned respect oh heard you
mentioned me getting banned absolutely
what up that you made a song and youtube
took you down for it
yeah very rude uh did you did you look
up him it just stands for amateur radio
so oh is that what it is
yeah it's not like an acronym oh it's
weird yeah i know i'm pretty sure we've
had this conversation before exactly
like this yeah i'm feeling something
because we were talking about internet
over ham radio before
and like the the amount of data that can
transmit on it is very low it's like a
low frequency or something
yeah
all right let's see we got we'll get a
couple more in here
red hood 13 says there's a rumor going
around that radiohead will have a
surprise performance at your upcoming
event i heard that rumor too i heard i
heard this rumor that's right no that
was a trick during occupy that claimed
radiohead was coming and they weren't
remember that
yeah every day like they're kind and
there's someone walking down like really
yeah and then they had thousands of
people show up [ __ ] radiohead would
be and then after that every single day
yeah i remember it was a huge there was
it was like
occupy wall street was flooded with
people everywhere and it was it was it
was a great prank
radio internet access digital radio i
don't know i'm sorry
metal works
says
thought uh thought so getting a skate
rock music festival chuck trice mcraed
isn't too far from you i'd drive up from
arizona for that dude that would be
awesome yeah let's do it skate rock with
a shooting competition no
not at the same time no look look look
we have uh
we have weapons that can't fire so i
shouldn't call them opens we have like
replicas and i tell people the rules and
the first thing i'll do is before
they're out to go anywhere near any gun
ever is like here's the replica do you
know the rules yes i'll tell them the
rules and then when they just wave it
around i'm like you will never fire
we're not talking about average joes
there's professionals that do certain
circuits and it's just like any kind of
profession like basketball or sports
there's professional shooters and they
compete professionally so having like a
professional shooting competition i
think would be really cool we could set
up like bleachers and then have drills
yeah yeah that's exactly what they do
we'll put cameras all over the place so
people could be inside watching on
cameras at like the bar with like a nice
soda no alcohol yeah i think that would
be really cool if you combine all of
those and have a huge culture jam if you
do do a punk rock show don't book
teenage bottle rocket because they
require a vaccine to go to their shows
we will specifically ban them yeah
please because
i think they're my other fans yeah their
mosh pit has like a bouncy gym in it
yeah this
brian workman says they just shut shut
down my local walmart till saturday
morning said it was due to a labor
shortage they posted the details on the
local facebook page google mount vernon
ohio walmart
so on on the local facebook group for my
neighborhood people were complaining
that kfc was shut down they're like why
haven't they opened and everyone's like
dude they're all shutting down there's
no employees no one's working anymore
where do these people go why i mean a
lot of people are saying why work when
the dollar is devalued every single day
and they're getting 300 bucks a week
yeah not to work yeah i believe it's
government assistance right now i get
switching ham
or you can get 500 and you have to work
all the time
right
all right we'll get a couple more in
here
sewer turd says hipsters won't be
stealing your chickens in the night the
government will use the military to
seize resources from the responsible
self-reliant people to feed the
dependents in society that's typically
how communism goes right yeah i thought
about that and um
i think he surmised that point very well
and uh brings up a good one all right
civilized age custom says does no one
real else realize why it's called
television programming
telepathic programming via vision well
that's not true it's like a schedule
it's a good idea yeah yeah programming
was like
the program of the network they would
program the network to display content
so they'd have it lined up in a program
not to program you but now they may as
well just say it that way my friends if
you haven't already make sure you smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and go to timcast.com become a member
because we're gonna have a members only
segment coming up and i imagine it's
gonna be like very not family friendly
so you know just if you want to see a
lot of cussing and hear a lot of naughty
words and talk about growth stuff i like
the important stuff though you know what
i mean like the things that we need to
address in the society then definitely
timcast.com members only segment you can
follow the show at tim cast irl
basically everywhere except tic toc
because they banned us and you can
follow me personally at tim cast joe you
want to shout out anything uh you just
find me joey b tunes t-o-o-n-z could
find me everywhere just you know pissing
off tick-tockers influencers and
bucking the
system and you can find me on
youtube.com forward slash we are change
i have way too much fun on that channel
and i hope to see some of you guys there
you can always follow me ian
crossland.net it'll link to all my
social media and to the people that
responded about the gpl and everything i
really appreciate it if you were some
people were saying that you can take it
and make it private if there was some
things i was saying that was wrong
please contact me via twitter or mine's
direct message and uh i'd love to
clarify that stuff thanks for coming
thank you guys for tuning in tonight we
had a blast as always i'm really looking
forward to this bonus episode because i
sense that our spicy guests gonna get
even spicier off youtube um you guys can
follow me on twitter at sour patch lids
our guests for tomorrow are confirmed
right yes and who are they uh they are
viva frey and robert barnes yeah very
excited we normally don't say who the
guests are going to be in advance but uh
as long as they're coming they are i'm
very excited they were fun good good
guys good guys so uh thanks for hanging
out everybody go to timcast.com we'll
see you all in that member segment and
again thanks for hanging out bye guys
you